[Musique]
je demande au photographe d'avoir la
gentillesse de petites et le plateau car
maintenant le débat va commencer et
avant de donner la parole aux invités je
vais me tourner vers lidar bois pour
savoir quels sont déjà les questions qui
sont parvenus asvp s'il est d'ores et
déjà possible d'en faire une synthèse
guy dartois vous avez la parole oui bien
c'est difficile pour le moment encore de
faire une synthèse joseph pasteur je
viens de feuilleter plus de 2000 fiche
et je n'ai vu que la moitié des fiches
qui sont là et je peux vous assurer que
la seule lecture de ces fiches
constituerait une émission passionnante
il ya une telle charge de haine des
affirmations tellement tranché que l'on
se croirait revenu 35 ans en arrière des
téléspectateurs ont téléphoné simplement
pour dire vive pétain d'autres au moins
aussi nombreux pour dire qu'il mérite la
mort les partisans de pétain ont deux
arguments
boulogne sur scène beaucoup de français
étaient contents que pétain signe
l'armistice car nous allions au massacre
ou bien qu aurait fait la france si à la
place de pétain nous avions eu un gaou
leiter et les partisans de la résistance
accuse pétain est le seul à avoir livré
ses propres troupes ressortissants pour
cela il mérite la mort et à profiter de
l'armistice pour instaurer une terreur
une nouvelle terreur blanche avec ses
sections spéciales et le tribunal d'état
c'est cela son plus grand crime plus
encore que sa collaboration avec le
régime nazi ou un habitant de saverne
qui dit je me fais le porte parole des
alsaciens et des lorrains qui pensent
que pétain les a vendus il y en a
vraiment des centaines et des centaines
de cet ordre là quant à l'émission de ce
soir elle a bien entendu provoquer des
réactions et je dois vous dire que ces
réactions sont partagées mais dans les
deux camps il y à une téléspectatrice
qui dit j'ai honte d'être français je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on remet en
question ce qui s'est passé trente ans
après je suis indigné par cette émission
une autre fiche débat scandaleux avec
des collaborateurs notoire je
désapprouve entièrement le débat de ce
soir je considère que c'est une
réhabilitation déguisé en revanche il y
à de très nombreux téléspectateurs qui
remercie antenne 2 d'avoir eu le courage
de montrer cette émission car dit il il
est bon de faire connaître l'histoire
les passions apaisée mais les passions
apaisé et je me demande si elles le sont
vraiment ce soir
la guitare moi je présume que vous serez
en mesure d'ici environ une demi-heure
de nous présenter une synthèse
infiniment plus affinée que celle que
vous venez de vous donner et pour cause
donc nous si vous voulez bien nous nous
allons commencer tout de suite le débat
ici pas en abordant une question qui
préoccupe le sait depuis longtemps
beaucoup de français fallait-il ou ne
fallait-il pas demander l'armistice en
juin 1940 et j'ajouterai une question
subsidiaire qui a été soulevé dans un
message du général de gaulle qui si j'ai
bonne mémoire et du 26 juin est ce que
pour cela il fallait faire appel au
maréchal pétain est-ce que n'importe qui
n'aurait pas pu demander l'armistice aux
albums alors amiral je sais que vous
vous prétendez que on n'y avait pas
d'autre solution que de demander
l'armistice en juin 1940 c'est bien ça
je suis un enfant le président et je
suis le dernier survivant du haut
commandement maritime français que vous
avez dit l'adjoint puis le successeur de
l'amiral darlan à la tête de la marine
jusqu'en novembre 42 et aussi le
confident maréchal envoyé au général de
gaulle en août 44 pour tenter de
réconcilier des français dans la vérité
pour leur bien commun et je suis dans le
même état d'esprit à ces divers titres
je suis témoin
de choses que de suivre grâce à vous
hommage à ceux qui ont organisé cette
soirée de pouvoir dire enfin aux
français car il ya trente ans que
j'attends ce moment là je suis témoin
que l'engagement franco britannique du
28 mars de ne pas faire de paix séparée
n'a pas été un pacte solennel comme l'a
écrit churchill mais un simple
communiqué de presse de portée limitée
et à usage surtout un terme je suis
témoin car vivant à douvres 27 mai
mandaté par le général weygand et
l'amiral darlan pour soutenir la tête de
pont et donc pas pour les battues et
j'ai trouvé des anglais commençons à ce
robin se rembarquer sans nous avoir
prévenus rupture d'alliance antérieure à
notre propre demande d'armistice
voyez-vous les anglais retirer d'orbit
sans que les américains en met aucune
dans le jeu et nous étions seuls en face
du nazisme et du communisme unis il ne
faut pas l'oublier
nos dirigeants civils
ça n'était témoins et le général de
gaulle lui même avec son réduit breton
nageait dans le dire réalisme le
transport de l'armée française en
afrique dont on a tellement parlé était
une utopie
exemple le 15 juin le président perdre
et nous nos demandes de transporter en
afrique cinq cent mille hommes sont
d'ailleurs pouvoir nous dire où et quand
pareils masse humaine sera rassemblée
nous répondons enverra pour 500 mais
commençons par trente mille hommes et
nos réunissant huit gants transport de
troupes dans la région la pallice
bordeaux de vernon de son coulé il ya
des pertes peu importe mais quand nos
bateaux sont rassemblés qu'en un instant
madail price en ex-zone escorte aérienne
et navale eh bien on trouve à peine
quelques personnes à faire monter à bord
des militaires c'est pour ça qu'on a
donné match il ya au début
alors voilà voilà quelle était la
situation
la capitulation de l'armée seul aurait
doublé le nombre des prisonniers de
guerre
plonger la métropole dans l'anarchie et
attiré les allemands en afrique
empêchant plus tard le débarquement
américain
je pourrais parler et cette solution est
comparable peut-être à l'armée belle à
la solution belge
je voudrais en parler plus longuement
cependant puisque j'y suis je dois dire
que la belgique ne sais pas du tout s'il
n'est pas du tout dans la même situation
que la france la france avait un empire
la capitulation mené l'armée allemande
dans nos propres c'est un fait je crois
que tous les militaires à l'époque l'ont
reconnu
de plus la france n'a vécu sous
l'occupation qu'avec d'un ravitaillement
maritime important je ne veux pas vous
infliger la lecture de quelques chiffres
mais en gros la moitié de ce que les
français ont mangé jusqu'en 1943 a été
importé par mr
alors quelle autre solution nous
affrétons canapé puis que je suis prêt à
discuter dans ta quelles autres
solutions de nos prêteurs de la
capitulation pêche et bien il ya la
solution churchill la solution churchill
11 9 11 juin à briare lutter ville par
ville rue par rue maison par maison et
ses cd si vous voulez la guérilla sans
fin l'épuisement et j'appellerai ça
aujourd'hui le génocide
démographiquement l'armistice à sauver
notre pays ou contrer carnage à l'état
s'est trouvé devant ça c'était la
préoccupation forte c'était sa
préoccupation fondamentale si après la
saignée de la première guerre nous
avions dû en supporter une eau dont si
drastiques et ben la france aurait été
vidé et nous ne saurions pas si mal si
nombreux ce soir à en parler alors vous
demande pardon mais bon elle est en nous
et mesurez vous avons très bien compris
l'essentiel de votre argumentation et
maintenant je voudrais dire à la leur à
la solution française je vous ai dit la
solution beige la solution sur le
génocide alors la solution française on
n'a pas trouvé une autre ça a été la
remise tice dans l'auberge appel
l'honneur n'est ce pas une condition
d'honneur essentielle la non reddition
de la flotte voilà si vous voulez vous
rencontrer notre entrevue dans tout je
suis prêt à porter mais nous aurons
certainement l'occasion d'en parler donc
il faudrait que je prenne vertueux là je
vais me réveiller il ya pour normes
istis une question capitale coca
l'historien n'a jamais soulevé c'est que
il y avait une manière de faire la
guerre à l'époque c'était les formations
laïques et bien c'est ça qui est routes
troublées vous parce que les communistes
ne résistait pas c'est nous qui
résistent yeux ils ont commencé à agir
cannes août
1941 et avec des moyens contraires à la
promotion l'oeil qui s'ils voulaient de
l'armistice été fait dans le cadre d'une
guerre classe à partir du moment où vous
êtes traduisez la guerre subversive
évidemment tous ces pourris peu à peu et
nous sommes dans les conséquences voilà
ce que vient de dire très bien
moralement on n'est pas du tout d'accord
avec vous avez non je ne crois pas parce
qu'effectivement il me semble que ce
problème de l'armistice et le problème
fondamental parce que c'est de là que
tout est parti c'est l'acte fondamental
qui a été commis en 1940 et cet acte
d'ailleurs il s'avère que tous les jours
nous apprenions que des situations
analogues se pose dans le monde est ce
qu'un peuple doit lorsqu'il est occupé
lorsqu'il subit une invasion est ce que
ce peuple doit subir doit accepter doit
se coucher doit tendre la main à
l'ennemi en un mot doit-il collaborer
c'est ça le problème combien doit-il se
battre alors il ya deux attitudes elles
sont fondamentales et sont complètement
différentes et opposées les unes aux
autres le pet a choisi de se coucher il
a choisi de tendre la main de gaulle a
choisi de se battre et on ne peut pas
sortir de là en réalité en choisissant
de
collaborer pétain accepter toute la
suite est toute la suite ne sont que des
incidents des incidents dramatiques des
détails épouvantable mais dès l'instant
où il a déposé la souveraineté française
entre les mains de l'ennemi à partir de
ce moment là tout était possible et
c'est est grave parce que ils n'avaient
pas utilisé tous moyens on peut encore
encore encore à la rigueur imaginez
qu'un pays se remette complètement jette
ses armes et sa sa puissance et son
indépendance auprès de son adversaire
mais quand tous les moyens ont été
utilisés
or vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure la
france avait une armée de l'air qui
était presque intacte c'était à peine
battu la france à busnes flop qui était
absolument intacts qui n'avaient jamais
servi elle avait quantité d'hommes et sa
jeunesse qui n'avait pas été appelé et
puis elle avait ce qu'à sauver la russie
l'espace cet espace asplet l'afrique du
nord et ça s'appelait l'afrique noire et
j'ai lu récemment dans un livre de
monsieur payolle qui vous ne pouvez pas
suspecter puisque il a suivi aveuglément
pétain pendant toute la période de vichy
puis ans suite d'arlette c'est qu'il a
rencontré le 20 août le général noguès à
casablanca waraba et qu'il lui a dit du
17 juin au 27 juin je n'ai cessé
d'envoyer télégramme weygand en adjurant
weygand commandant en chef et [ __ ] de
venir en afrique du nord la résistance
était possible et de la toux serait
reparti mais dès l'instant où on avait
mis entre les mains de l'ennemi la
souveraineté française où pétain pour
constituer son équipe a été obligé de
demander aux allemands de ne pas rentrer
à bordeaux car il n'a pu constituer son
gouvernement et commence à gouverner que
parce que les allemands ont accepté
d'une pop et bordeaux alors dès cet
instant là dès ce moment-là tous suivent
et la persécution des juifs le fait
première rendue aux allemands les plus
jeunes et politique le fait qu décor
concentration que les résistants
français d'aidé pour suivre et livré aux
allemands pour aller mourir dans les
camps tout ça a suivi c'était impossible
vous l'avez vu vous l'avez vu vous avez
vu que petit à petit il est obligé de
tout céder et maître isorni dans un de
ses livres l'a dit à plusieurs reprises
il a dit oui pétain essayé de protester
mais ça ne donnait rien il ne pouvait
pas et rappelez-vous que dès les
premières semaines l'armistice a été
violée puisque dans les jours qui ont
suivi alsace et lorraine a subi un
régime d'annexion qui n'était pas prévue
par amnesty dont dans les premiers jours
cet armistice et
je termine donc par conséquent si vous
voulez tous les efforts to cette fameuse
politique d' à servir à rien puisque le
défenseur de péta reconnaissent
eux-mêmes qu'il est beau protester et
que ça de mener nulle part s'amenait à
thin man
alors ou maîtrise hormis où l'amiral
enfants pour répondre à monsieur le fond
je me dis que michèle
je suis pour une fois d'accord avec
monsieur lefranc
lorsqu'il dit avec le général de gaulle
que tout est parti de l'armistice il est
bien évident qu'à partir du moment où il
y avait un armistice et que la guerre a
et se prolonger pendant quatre ans un
certain nombre de choses on était
inévitable
mais ce qui comptait c'est ce que disait
tout à l'heure l'amiral darlan
c'est d'abord l'amiral offshoring et moi
ce qui compte
c'était précisément
l'élément qu'a apporté l'armistice
ce n'était pas un abandon total
de souveraineté
parce que ya une chose que vous ne
pouvez pas contester c'est que
et maurice thorez et jacques duclos long
98 % des français était derrière le
maréchal pour l'armistice il y avait par
conséquent dans l'acte d'armistice
quelque chose de légitime du fait que le
peuple français unanimes là pouvait il
avait quelque chose de légitime dans
l'armistice du fait que la france avait
parfaitement le droit de fait cette
suspension d'armes
séparer le président de la république
disait devant la haute cour de justice
qui jugeaient le maréchal pétain en juin
1940 après la bataille du nord
l'angleterre n'avait plus d'armes
n'avions pas vu la question des chars et
non je viens de commettre une erreur
voilà la citation du prix dans la
république celle que je commençais c'est
celle de winston churchill qui est
encore plus importante lebrun déclare à
partir du moment où l'un des deux pays
signataires d'une convention comme celle
du 28 mars et c'était un communiqué de
presse retient une partie de ses forces
pour sa défense hop au lieu de les
risques et aux combats communs comme la
fel empire britannique
il peut toujours dans la forme s'armer
d'un papier pour nous rappeler les
obligations qui sont inscrits il n'a
plus l'autorité morale nécessaire pour
dire je ne puis vous délier
engagement et conséquence de l'armistice
c'est le tueur gilles qui va le dire au
général george en juin 40
après la bad après la bataille du nord
l'angleterre n'avait plus tard nous
n'avions pas vu la question des chars et
celle de l'aviation sur un plan
suffisant l'armistice nous en sommes
rendu service
hitler a commis une faute en l'accordant
il aurait dû aller en afrique du nord
s'en emparer pour poursuivre sur
l'egypte nous aurions eu alors une tâche
bien difficile l'armistice
arrêter les allemands l'armistice a été
beaucoup plus puissants que l'armée
française est que l'armée anglaise
réunis et le général de gaulle dans son
premier discours a dit la france n'est
pas seule elle n'est pas seule elle
n'est pas seule la réalité la réalité
politique la réalité militaire c'était
que la france était à ce moment là seul
seul seul et rappelez-vous hall raynaud
adressée au président roosevelt un appel
désespéré et il disait si vous ne
répondez pas à cet appel je serai obligé
de consentir l'armistice ou d'autres
consentiront l'armistice et bien
roosevelt n'a pas répondu ou sevele
préparer les élections et à ce moment là
l'allemagne était l'allié de l'urss et
l'angleterre étaient rentrées chez elles
et l'amérique préparait ces élections il
nous faisait payer cash and carry les
armements que nous lui demandons c'est
ça la réalité si bien que l'armistice a
fait reculer les allemands les a arrêtés
à préserver l'afrique du nord a empêché
ville traverse l'espagne pour aller en
afrique du nord et c'est par l'armistice
c'est par l'armistice que les alliés ont
été sauvés
je freinais monsieur michel jouan pardon
monsieur freinet veut demander la parole
avant ont la maîtrise au rni je crois
qu'on pourra éternellement débattre sans
apporter de celui en définitive je veux
dire d'une logique rigoureuse sur les
avantages de ce que j'aurais
personnellement souhaité une
capitulation des armées et le départ du
gouvernement en angleterre dans un pays
libre comme l'ont fait tous les autres
pays de l'europe mais ce que je peux
dire
c'est que le gouvernement de vichy en
s'installant et particulièrement en
mettant à sa tête un homme de grand
prestige que le maréchal pétain
rentrait très exactement dans les vues
d'hitler
et pour le prouver
j'aimerais faire un écrit que j'ai signé
d'un pseudonyme
en septembre 41
dans les deux journaux clandestins le
deuxième que j'avais créé qui s'appelait
vérité au pluriel
et je donnais un article qui
s'intitulait ainsi français hitler vous
donne le sont méditez là
et c'est une citation de mein kampf que
je vais vous donner en septembre 41
j'étais déjà sous mandat d'arrêt depuis
plusieurs mois
quelques lignes
les gouvernements vaincu
n'ont guère l'habitude de se sentir si
mauvais que cela
parce que les vainqueurs sont assez rusé
pour leur confier la surveillance des
esclaves
et ces êtres sans caractère
exerce la plupart du temps cette affiche
aux dépens de leur propre peuple
un vainqueur a visé c'est hitler qui
parle dans mein kampf
on aurait dû être prévenu
invaincu à aviser
n'imposera ses exigences au vainqueur
que par étapes successives
c'est bien ce qu'il a fait et il a le
droit d'escompté comme c'est toujours le
cas de celui qui se soumet volontiers
man que le vaincu ne trouve plus
d'impôts que des actes d'oppression pris
à part
une raison suffisante
de reprendre les armes
et j'ai tiré de votre livre mon chèr
mettre à la page 207
quelques mots que disait pétain à des
réfugiés laura expulsés dont il recevait
les représentants dans son bureau
il lors des assauts si je cite votre
livre je reçois des ordres
d'antan bar d'à côté
ces offres sont parfois très dur et ils
doivent être exécutés voilà ce qui a
donné l'armistice de russie n'y avait
pas eu l'armistice la france était
entièrement occupée et puis après et
puis après emi avait lu ar millions de
français qui étaient partis réellement
il est on vous dit c'est à la gloire
j'aurais préféré hong hao l'eyetoy au
rang de titulaire n'était pas un danger
pour le peuple français
hitler n'était pas une menace la france
n'était pas protégé david était plus
facile de partir
plus difficile maîtrise ordi mais je
souhaitais caution d'années a terminé
sur l'intervention monsieur michel je
sois tu as des problèmes à gérer un peu
le problème sur le terrain des faits
monsieur michel est un historien
paraît que je ne le suis pas
effectivement je ne cache pas que j'ai
été résistant mais voilà trente ans que
j'étudie la deuxième guerre mondiale et
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de documents
que de ce côté de la salle on aurait
intérêt à lire pour ne pas répéter
toujours les mêmes choses vous aussi il
y as mais nous allons y arriver à ces
documents si vous devez nous allons
confronter notre connaissance de
documents quand vous voudrez
premièrement je voudrais dire que l'
empire français
en 20 40 étaient incomparablement plus
fort qu'en novembre 42 que la flotte à
ce moment était la troisième flotte du
monde en novembre 42 elle avait été
considérablement
by que des avions américains
commençaient à arriver était monté à
casablanca qu'ils arrivent et or in de
500 et que les constructions
aéronautiques en france à ce moment si
on avait pu en déplacer une partie si la
guerre n'avait pas éclaté aussi
rapidement c'est qu'en gestion
aéronautique en france et est
suffisamment développé faut qu'il y ait
un changement dans l'équilibré des
forces aériennes j'ajoute que la
population leur empire et pas seulement
le général noguès il ya un livre que
vous pourriez lire monsieur que vous me
connaissez certainement pas le livre de
monsieur truffiers les est le seul qui
étudie le problème est oui mais oui mais
oui c'est le seul qui a étudié le
problème de la lutte en afrique du nord
et par conséquent de cette russie qui
était sur place témoignent que la
population et d'un afrique du nord tout
en cuir indigènes compris étaient tout à
fait enthousiaste pour continuer le
combat deuxième point vous avez fait un
portrait idyllique de l'armistice vous
avez dit que l'armistice était dans
l'honneur en grains parce qu'on avait
préservé la flotte l'honneur consiste
uniquement réservé une flotte et la
clause qui impose et au gouvernement de
vichy de livrer les émigrés allemand
cette clause ne devait pas contre
l'honneur de la france l'argovien
délégué du gouvernement de vichy ont
protesté c'est vrai mais en définitive
ces exilés ont été livrés à l'allemagne
qui ça c'est pas une marque de
déshonneur je ne sais pas ce qu'est le
déshonneur j'ajoute que le diktat ce
diktat tout de même le régime de vichy
n'a cessé par la suite de protester
contre ce diktat tellement il était dur
breault utile qu'à imposer aux français
le paiement de 400 millions de francs
par jour de convention d'armistice de
frais d'occupation qui aurait permis de
nourrir d'habiller 10 millions de
soldats français qui a permis à la
france avec l'art en france à
l'allemagne avec l'argent français
d'ajouter l'économie française le
gouvernement de vichy n'a cessé de
protester quand vous vous présentez
comme un beau succès et je voudrais
revenir le temps sur un troisième point
qui me paraît capt'ain masse que je ne
comprends pas toute cette histoire je
sais que je me suis interrogée se
commande se fait qu'après tant d'années
alors qu'on a couru après une
collaboration qu'il terre n'a jamais vu
accordé alors qu'on sentait très bien
qu'il n'y avait rien à espérer du côté
allemand comment se fait-il qu'on n'ait
pas compris à vichy qu'en définitive en
faisait le jeu de lutter et je vais vous
en donner une fin puisque vous
connaissez les documents aujourd'hui
comme si tu as des documents allemands
moi je vais vous en citer un
lorsque hitler était sur le point
d'accorder l'armistice ils devront beau
document diplomatique allemand
doctrinaire est sur le point d'accorder
la miss il est allé rencontrer nous
souligne nous souligner à ce moment
voulaient tout dévorer nous souligner
vous répandre la grèce voulait prendre
nice voulait prendre la tunisienne ils
ont la france et partout il faut se
servir et hitler va donner une leçon de
sagesse pour fille que le coach yann à
admirer hitler a dit n'est pas du tout
si nous demandons pas aux français la
flotte ira en afrique du nord et c'est
ça qu'il faut que nous évitions à tout
prix en laissant la flotte en france
amiral vous faisiez exactement ce que
dit elle voulait qu'on le fasse y ait
ensuite hitler à continuer à expliquer à
nous souligne si nous imposons votre loi
à la france d'une part nous n'aurons pas
à cet administrateur pour administrer la
france et d'autre part tout ce que nous
pouvons imposer aux français les
français ne voudront pas parce que ce
sera imposée par nous par contre si nous
arrivons à préserver un gouvernement
français théoriquement libres qui paraît
pas libre mais qui ne sera pas en
réalité parce qu'il ne pourra pas faire
autre chose que ce que nous voulons
faire parce que l'armistice nous permet
de faire tout ce que nous voulons alors
à ce moment nous imposeront aux français
ce que nous voulons et l'accepterons pas
que ça n'apparaîtra décidées par le
gouvernement et mousseline s'est soumis
par conséquent se considère qu' il y
avait une possibilité de continuer la
lutte dans l' empire
quant à dire que hitler aurait produit
l'espagne il a jamais traversé khiter
des problèmes méditerranéen ne l'ont
jamais intéressé vous devez le savoir
des problèmes méditerranée ne l'ont
jamais intéressé absolument pas le
sculpteur a pu se précipiter sur l'union
soviétique ici le précipiter en tout cas
c'est une grande inconnue c'est suppose
également que les espagnols qui serait
prêté ce qui n'est pas sûr du tout
deuxièmement l'armistice était tellement
dur qui l'a d'art haute et la france et
que vous n'avez cessé de monter ces
contres et enfin hitler à appliquer en
france la même politique qu'il a
appliquée dans tous les pays qui étaient
occupés à savoir il a gardé en réserve
un certain nombre de collaborateurs
avérés et détient au nord en france il
nous a pas mis au pouvoir a pu en
hongrie en roumanie nulle part et
partout il a gardé au pouvoir des
conservateurs qui avaient une grande
réputation et qui était estimé de la
population et dont il pouvait se servir
et bien il se trouve que pour la france
ce grand homme ça a été pétain
vient alors amiral vous répondez à
monsieur michel mais uniquement sur le
point précis de la flap c'est bien ce
que vous soyez thé vert réponses sur
leur mystique puisqu'on l'a déjà dit
d'abord qu'il y avait une question
d'honneur de notre part de ne pas
remettre nos bateaux aux allemands pour
qu'ils servent contre les anglais bon
les anglais sont venus à bordeaux ils
ont tout nous leur avons dit que nos
bateaux resterait français où seraient
détruits et nous ont quittés satisfaits
et ce dès ce n'est qu'ultérieurement que
churchill à retenir jamais les anglais
ne nous ont demandé de la flotte passer
en angleterre je tiens à le dire ici
vous avez châtier les garonnais après la
politique alors que l'acte est alors
je vous bien
les amiraux français jean relations
marianne qu'est ce que vous voulez on se
bat et moi je me bats depuis l'âge de 19
ans eh bien c'est ce qu'était vraiment
examiner tous les problèmes le général
noguès s'il avait dit qu'on pouvait
continuer la guerre matricon on l'aurait
fait en vous n'êtes pas du tout que
voulez vous laissez moi vous devons
raisonner généraux moreels le voir et
vous raisonnez on ne mettra pas mais
vous raisonner uniquement en fonction de
votre expérience personnelle hors amiral
vous des deux autres mais nous
résoudrons sous développement
une affaire entendue mais reste pas
moins que vous l'avez perdue pendant
rixe qui s'est perdue pour le moindre
mal si on la gagne et c'est pas la
marine qui a fait alors j'ai pas la
marine qui a vu la foule est venue elle
s'écoule et
se battent ou et laurent bonnart a cours
dans le feu de l'action de voir sur le
regard de dieu en pense on a peur
de confusion si vous voulez nous allons
reprendre un peu tous les points qui ont
été volés puis tilly hqe il ya tellement
de choses inexactes qu'ils ont dit c'est
pas possible
disons que il il ya deux thèses en
présence lune qui défend bien de ce côté
ci affirme que l'armistice était
inévitable et que l'armistice à protéger
les français pendant une certaine
période et l'autre qui est celle des
français libres que nous connaissons
depuis déjà longtemps et qui consiste à
dire au fond il eût mieux valu à voir en
france 1 go leiter
car les français ne se serait peut-être
pas endormi pendant deux ans comme ça a
été le cas il faut bien le dire jusqu'au
mois jusqu'en 1942 à l'abri du képi du
maréchal pétain voilà attendu sous vichy
des français souhaitaient un gaou leiter
sûrement mais alors jamais notre ange il
souhaitait un goal acteurs mais on
pouvait souhaiter volant attendait mais
pas le soleil
nous avons ici un historien américain
monsieur baxter qui eux ne pas être à
l'historien engagée
s'est enchaîné ses qualités parce que
ces messieurs veulent qu'on dise on est
tellement la vie des choses que vous
menez un dossier qui soit complet
monsieur paxton prend un dossier
incomplet qui prend le dossier allemand
il oublie de regarder qu'un dossier
français en angleterre aux etats-unis en
espagne au vatican et ailleurs
qui me répond j'aurais bien voulu voir
le dossier français qui hélas était
fermée à moi et tout les autres
historiens vous êtes parti trop jeune
pour être baptisé historiens peut-être
pas mais ce qui est absurde mais
c'est que c'est hitler lui même qui n'a
pas voulu nommer aux gaiters en france
parce que comme michel a dit il beaucoup
plus économe pour lui a laissé
l'administration de la france aux
français et il a il à expliquer tout
cela très soigneusement amélie et senna
messieurs le pas du tout pas du tout à
l'écouté j'ai lu mein kampf quand
j'étais jeune je viens d'ailleurs il
vient la boîte allemande et il hésite
avait dit se sentir parfaitement
diplomatique également que vous avez lu
ils ont paru dans quelle édition mais
lesquels les documents diplomatiques
également que vous dites avoir lu son
nom vous me parlez vous moi je vous
parle de documents de l'accusation vita
sur l'allemagne et l'italie les
documents diplomatiques ils ont parlé de
colliger les élus leur
249,45 de la chance n'était pas publiés
attendez attendez le
suivi depuis mais je continue à lire un
lent départ et tout enlèvement
et c'est pareil ne paraît plus savoir
comment se dit que moi je publie des
livres et vous vous les connaissez pas
je ne lisais pas vous les utilisez
canada selon un accident avec ses
réalités pas tous en même temps c'est
parlons avec sérénité monsieur michel
avait voulu les débats du procès de
nuremberg me certainement avait voulu
mais surtout que les allemands ont dit
et cocktails notamment el général jodl
c'est que la grande faute d'hitler cesse
avait été d'accorder l'armistice à la
france et que leur défaite était venue
de là c'est ce qui a été proclamée par
les généraux allemands parce que c'est
une évidence historique vous vous avez
assez beau jeu de dire il fallait un
voltaire pour continuer la lutte en
afrique n'était pas possible d'aller en
afrique avec des éléments permettant de
résister et si nous continuons la guerre
en afrique les allemands qui étaient
très intéressés par la méditerranée les
allemands qui étaient très intéressés
par la méditerranée arrivait sur les
bords de la méditerranée
il arrivait sur les bornes
rien ne pouvait
nous arriver sur les bords de la
méditerranée nous souffle et à lille ou
à venir et guzet témoignages la chercher
je ne vois pas pourquoi vous récusez le
témoignage de churchill et le témoignage
des généraux enfin que et puis ajoutons
quelque chose dès l'instant que tout un
peuple et solidaire d'un acte quiz si
vous condamner cet acte comme vous le
faites c'est ce peuple m'aime que vous
prendre et on vous dit de l'armistice
est un crime vous dit le peuple français
madame d'énergie 6 mai ville on essaie
s'est accusé la france
n'accusait la france qu'a la france
étaient unanimes mais vous avez raison
en ce sens que les français dans leur
quasi-totalité
souhaitait qu'il soit mis fin au combat
car ils étaient sans espoir mais les
français il y aurait complètement la
différence qu'il peut y avoir entre un
armistice est une capitulation il disait
ça suffit ça c'est vrai mais ne disait
pas armistice mais la tête était
l'occasion est condamnée par le code
militaire c'est là qu'elle ment la
capitulation et la reddition de l'état
des passionnés par le code de remède
remonte à l'adversaire n'est pas trop
donné remettre et à la viola messieurs
le français de formule qui ne veut rien
dire
vous avez vu tout à l'heure un film qui
vous a tout de même on pourrait dire
bien des choses sur le film mais dans
l'incertitude et honnête vous avez vu
que l'homme qui parlait assez foule qui
l'acclamait remettait à l'adversaire
quand il était essayé ce qui la rend pas
dans la rue mais laissez moi parler
quand il essayait de défendre une
politique de restaurer une nation qui
étaient sous la botte alors qu'il a dit
c'est vrai mon honneur à moi est de
rester au milieu d'une population
malheureuse sans armée et sans marine et
il a fait quelque chose il a partagé ce
point il a essayé ils à nous ça a été
chaque jour une résistance aux exigences
allemandes et vous le disiez ontario et
puis au nigeria
quels étaient les hommes c'était au tour
d'une arrivée en tête à ce moment là
pour défendre sa politique
ce sont des jeunes y aurait six ans
autour de vous aujourd'hui s'il vous
plaît monsieur tg a demandé la parole de
petitjean un grand moment
j'aimerais tout de même rappeler ce qu'a
été cette collaboration sur le sol
national
ce ne sont pas uniquement les discours
et des manifestations devant les foules
la collaboration ce sont des actes des
faits les mesures prises
signé par philippe pétain
je prendrai quelques exemples
absolument indiscutable
l'armistice est à peine signé
nous avons
consenti à livrer aux allemands les
réfugiés allemands qui étaient en france
avant même qu'il ne les réclame et alors
qu'il était possible de les faire partir
nous les mettons en résidence surveillée
pour être bien sûr de pouvoir les leur
donner le jour hui les réclameront nous
leur livrons
nous leur livrons
49 légionnaires allemand qui avait servi
dans la légion étrangère française qui
bien sûr n'était pas visée par l'article
19 de la convention d'admission ils les
réclament nous les leur livrons
deux mois après statut des juifs
philippe pétain maréchal de france mais
son nom sous jacente as-tu des juifs et
puis dans les mois qui vont venir il
ajoutera des mesures complémentaires par
deux autres lois successives
c'est un affront
ranimant de tout ce qu'est la morale la
tradition le passé de la france
c'est une abomination
non seulement on les exclut la fonction
publique on les spolient de leurs biens
mais ça n'est rien encore ça n'est rien
encore parce qu'il faut voir ce que ça a
aidé sur le terrain la collaboration
on arrache les petits enfants juifs à
leurs parents
et ce sont des gendarmes français
et des miliciens français de vichy qui
participent à ces rats ou non mais 4000
au camp de drancy de mes yeux de mes
yeux j'ai vu débarquer pendant des
semaines des trains au camp de gurs dans
les basses pyrénées des gosses de 4 à 12
ans par son père et par centaines toutes
les semaines pleurant et bt on n'avait
pas pris leur nom on ne savait pas le
nom de leurs parents des gendarmes
français les coups c'est grand le camp
comme un troupeau mais pauvre petit mot
tout seuls leurs en hurlant rappelant
leur mère qu'est ce qu'on en a fait au
nom de la collaboration sous le nom du
maréchal pétain sous sa responsabilité
politique et morale qu'est ce qu'on en a
fait tous ces petits juifs et bien dans
les semaines qui ont suivi on les a
renvoyés aux allemands pour qui les
volent à mathausen et à au ficg ses
dessins la collaboration c'était ça la
collaboration avec des remords après des
scrupules peut-être fait une abomination
c'est une participation au génocide
crime abominable réprimé par le code
pénal sous les champions les plus
sévères et puis et puis est ce tout et
ce tous
livraisons à l'allemagne par les soins
du gouvernement de vichy
d'otages et même d'otages qu'on
assassine
vous savez m
un attentat commis contre un
aspirant de la kriegsmarine les
allemands exigent 50-otages sens à moins
touchante otages à moins que les
français ne condamne immédiatement à man
j andreu
en 24 heures dans une loi abominable
dans une voie aux mines amont institut
ce cette section spéciale on s'en va
dans les prisons des fonctionnaires
français des policiers français en
uniformes français au nom du maréchal de
france on s'en va dans les prisons
chercher si pauvre malheureux qu'on
avait jugé dans les mois précédant
condamné à quelques semaines à quelques
mois de prison pour des délits
correctionnelle on les amène hébété sans
savoir ce qui leur arrivait de vente un
tribunal qui en une matinée entre eux
dans trois morts
comme cela ne suffisait pas on les a
d'ailleurs guillotiné lendemain matin le
maréchal pétain des appâts gracié
ces gens innocents croit condamné à mort
trois pays livré au bout un monde pour
l'apaiser comme ça ne suffisait pas eh
bien on s'en va dont les semaines qui
suivent créé à la place de cette section
spéciale supprimer un tribunal d'état
qui condamnera son tour à mort les trois
rescapés de la section spéciale à
châteaubriant c'est monsieur pêcheurs
sous l'autorité la responsabilité
politique du maréchal pétain sa
responsabilité politique et morale c'est
me fais c'est le ministre de l'intérieur
qui de sa main corrige la liste de
d'otages qu'il a fait établir par le
préfecture trobriand par mieux me tue
hornu par mieux ya un gamin de 16 ans le
petit moquait bien sûr il était fils
d'un comice il avait 16 ans il était
détenu au camp de châteaubriant il était
était au camp de châteaubriant parce
qu'il avait diffusé des tracts et on le
prend avec les 51 livre aux allemands
pour les faire fusiller
qu'est-ce que c'était encore que la
collaboration l'est permanente à
l'oeuvre de guerre allemande on leur a
livré la loi sur le co2 sainson me
travailleurs français pour leur usine de
guerre obligé de partir là-bas
travailler pour eux
l'amiral offrant l'amiral offensants et
propre quentin tignes et
profondément indigné du vote de cette
loi sur le st lô alors permettez nous de
conserver nos soldats mais
également de s'en est nourri laisser
terminer quelques mois encore
cette lutte acharnée contre la
résistance
alors que la zone libre étaient encore
libres
le gouvernement de vichy a délivré 240
carte d'identité française à des
policiers de la gestapo il les a
camouflé en policier français même des
papiers français et la carte tricolore
pour venir nous pourchasser à travers
toute la zone y détecter le poste
émetteur de liaison avec l'ong 40 postes
nous ont été pris par cc on n'a pas ces
policiers franco est ce ta peau sous le
signe du maréchal pétain sous sa
responsabilité politique et morale et
les 60 opérateurs ont été fusillés et
donc dont quelques anciens en se donnant
comme à toulouse la milice
la minus vous pouvez accepter la milice
ces tueurs ses assassins
2000 3000 4000 assassinat dans des
conditions abominables dans des
conditions abominables
créé par une loi de vichy sous la
responsabilité politique et morale de
philippe pétain
messieurs tous ces actes là ce sont des
crimes punis par le code pénal de la
peine de mort
puni par le code pénal de la peine de
mort et les faits sont là et personne ne
peut nier rien de ce que j'ai dit ne
peut être contesté tout cela c'est vrai
alors voilà ce que c'était que la
collaboration et voilà où on allait dans
l'engrenage satanique donc je félicite
l'amiral enfants
d'avoir su se dégager en novembre 42 à
monsieur arsenault marchiol jusqu'au
bout monsieur karachi mais il n'y est
pas résidence à une garde à vue
tu vas rester dans son gouvernement et
si vous avez vraiment pensé que son
gouvernement fort et la france est bien
ou mal je vous connais assez on savoir
que régisseur d'y rester si vous êtes
partis ce que vous saviez bien qu'il ne
servait que la collaboration des nations
unies je vous laisse
seul à la parole après quoi nous irons
svp parce que vous avez évoqué des
problèmes je connais très bien et
peut-être mieux que vous
je voudrais d'abord je voudrais d'abord
rappeler le discours
plus exactement le message que pétain a
envoyé au peuple français et que celui
ci n'a pas reçu parce qu'il était emmené
en captivité par les allemands il a dit
je n'ai eu qu'un seul but vous protéger
du pire et tout ce qui a été fait par
mois
tout ce que j'ai accepté consenti subi
que ce fût de gré ou de force ne l'a été
que pour vous sauvegardez car si je ne
pouvais plus être votre épée j'ai voulu
rester votre bouclier alors je dis ceci
il y a eu pendant l'occupation
des choses effrayantes effroyable et
celle à laquelle auquel vous avez fait
allusion et notamment ses sections
spéciales
je les ai vécu de très près mais il faut
se rappeler les circonstances oui il est
affreux
abominable qu'un gouvernement qui est en
face d'un gouvernement comme celui
d'hitler soit appelé à discuter des vies
humaines
car quel est le problème qui se pose le
gouvernement vous avez dit tout à
l'heure s'est trouvé en présence de
cette situation les allemands à la suite
d'un attentat contre un officier de la
kriegsmarine
les allemands réclament sans taj
et plus exactement il menace le
gouvernement français de faire fusiller
sentent otages c'est un problème
que nous pourrions aborder sans passion
un problème philosophique et morale plus
que politique qu'est ce que doit faire
un gouvernement
si il se dit je peux sauver un certain
nombre de vies humaines je vais
peut-être sacrifier des princes non je
vais peut-être sacrifier des principes
des principes de droit des principes
humains mais il ya cette chose il boit
sans écouter delgennes
nous avons vécu dans un tout autre dans
de tout autres circonstances quelque
chose qui se rapproche terriblement de
la situation qui était celle de la
france ce sont
les avions avec des otages on menace eh
bien on capitule on viole toutes les
lois on s'incline devant des gens qui
sont des bourreaux pour essayer de
sauver des vies humaines et c'est ce
qu'a fait le maréchal et vous croyez pas
qu'il l'a fait la mort dans l'âme
donc pour sauver
sentent otages on a sacrifié
six français j étais pourquoi parce que
j'ai plaidé devant ces juridictions et
les [ __ ] avec odette moreau qui a été
déporté nous étions côte à côte moi je
ne les ai pas été c'est ma chance mais
nous faisons le même travail essayer de
sauver des vies parce que nous savions
que si nous ne les sauve y ont pas aidé
viendrait peut-être beaucoup d'autres
qui seraient exécutés et vous avez dit
tout à l'heure mais chose qui est tout à
fait inexact dans le temps il ya eu une
première fois les allemands ont exigé 6
et les juridictions spéciales en ont
condamné trois qui ont été c'est vrai
c'est affreux qui ont été guillotinés je
sais ce que c'est quoi les mois j'ai
toute ma vie lutter contre la peine de
mort est en même temps dans le sacrifice
de ces hommes que nous allons regarder
comme des héros quelles que fussent
leurs opinions politiques
nous sommes dit eh bien elle il ya eu le
salut de santos je sais que c'est
affreux mais pensez à ce ton survécu et
ça s'est renouvelé plusieurs fois et
puis comme ça se renouvelait de telle
manière
car si vous voulez juger les hommes il
faut tout de même non pas se contenter
de regarder les phénomènes extérieurs
mais de sonder les reins de voir les
intentions alors vous vous rappelez si
vous ne vous l'a rappelé pas je vais
vous l'apprendre la lettre que le 34
tonnes 1943 pétain adressé à est clair
parce que précisément les menaces
allemande était plus en plus grande le
chantage à le monde surtout les français
avec tous ces otages qu'ils avaient
derrière les barbelés monsieur le
chancelier
je m'adresse à vous par la voie la plus
directe pour vous demander au nom des
principes sacrés de l'humanité
d'arrêter de trop sanglantes
représailles
parce que deux officiers allemands
viennent d'être lâchement assassiné par
des inconnus dont rien ne permet
d'affirmer que ce soit des français sans
français ont été déjà exécutées en deux
joues et d'autres sont menacées nous
sommes tous deux résolus à rechercher et
à châtier les coupables a lutté de tous
nos pouvoirs compter influences
étrangères qui ont armé leurs bras mais
je ne peux laisser verser le sang de
ceux qui n'ont pas pris part à ces
assassinats je trahirais mon peuple si
je ne vous adresse est points à 7 heures
une solennelle protestation ci refusant
d'entendre ma voix il vous faut encore
des otages et des victimes meuf fois ci
je me présenterais aujourd'hui même à
14h à la ligne de démarcation ou en
attendant votre décision je me
constituerai votre prisonniers et le
gouvernement a eu raison a empêché le
maréchal je n'ai pas terminé de se
constituer prisonnier et alors je
voudrais vous dire encore ceux ci
en ce qui concerne les juifs
ça a été le même besoin de protection
mais là encore il y a eu ce calcul
mais les chiffres sont officiels le
besoin de protection vous ne comprenez
pas que tout ça a été fait mais vous ne
reprenez pas ce qu'était hitler vous le
savez c'est comme si les mois par
l'arrêté pour les protéger c'était que
le gouvernement français voulait leur
donner un statut pour que les allemands
ne leur impose pas et puis on ne peut
pas serré la main d'hitler on ne peut
pas ne
pas serrer la
main
des roses mais tous n'y a pas d'erreurs
et je vous le dis tout de suite eu des
erreurs de féron n'y a pas d'erreur
deuxième je vous en ai besoin d une
région l'a d'abord amené une nouvelle at
il si vous me direz vous mais je
voudrais je voudrais avoir le droit de
terminer parce que monsieur telle gêne
au fond c'est vous qui avez porté le
débat dans ce qu'il a d'essentiel parce
qu'il est crucial et qu'elle 6e ils se
situent même en dehors de la politique
vis-à-vis de l'allemagne car il faut
bien dire qu'en définitive l'attitude de
la france a été telle latitude de la
france gouvernée par le maréchal pétain
a été telle qu'elle a été bénéfique aux
alliés le problème serait vous avez j'ai
été c'est entendu mais ça nous pourrons
discuter autrement ça n'est plus un
problème passionnel en est ce que vous
venez d'évoquer c'est un problème
passionnel mais c'est un problème sur
lequel nous sommes tous d'accord sur ce
qui lie à d'affreux dans certaines
choses mais lab la profonde
philosophie politique du maréchal a été
consentir le mal pour éviter un mal plus
grand encore c'est ça la réalité
profonde transmis à l'homme non attendez
que je termine sur l'egypte où les juifs
ça a été la même chose d'à la
seule hostilités que j'ai connu c'est
philippe pétain que je n'ai connu qu'en
prison mais que j'ai bien connu j'ai vu
un homme en prison avec tout cela peut
comporter surtout à sang la haine et
honnête de sa chance je suis ne suis pas
tout de suite je vais j'ai fait qu'aucun
avis comme sur francs vous n'avez pas
d'expérience sur larmoyant 90 ans après
avoir été maréchal de france ni chair
l'état alors il ya des différences
et bien c'est vrai que toute sa pensée
ça a été celle là essayer de protéger le
plus possible les français essayait de
sauver le pays du et prenant sur lui ce
qui pouvait être ce qui peut apparaître
la honte c'est vrai et c'est là où il
faut comprendre ce qu'est tesson mot
jusqu'au bout duquel il est allé et son
agonie en prison le monde il avait fait
vraiment le don de sa personne à la
france il protégeait les français il en
recevait des outrages mais il protégeait
les français évident a dit lui c'est
probablement l'homme auquel le peuple
français doit d'avoir sauvegardé le plus
de visu même car vous ne pensez pas
titulaire si pétain n'avait jamais rien
fait dans un certain ordre en essayant
de protéger les vies vous croyez qu'ils
clair les aurait laissés faire quelqu'un
dit tout à l'heure je crois que c'est
monsieur michel mais dans les autres
pays où il n'y avait pas de programme à
11 ans a été beaucoup par les ans par
mer sur une piste que vous en avez déjà
été beaucoup plus grave mais pas du tout
et alors c'était beaucoup plus graves
touchant et vous savez une chance est
toujours enterré gestion c'est toujours
terrible de parler de pourcentage quand
il s'agit de vies humaines mais tout de
même
nous avons rendez vous avec les
téléspectateurs qui se passionnent pour
ce qui vient des homélies pour répondre
à maîtriser mais très vite mais il avait
parfaitement posé le problème chez
laquelle g alors je vous pose de
questions primo quand on est en guerre
en der est ce que le seul souci c'est
d'économiser des vies humaines avait un
pétain at il reculé abandonné la villa
aux allemands sous prétexte de sauver
ses soldats deuxièmement gestion gens
d'air il fallait continuer à se battre
même si ça devait coûter les visuels
deuxièmement
vous croyez que ce n'est que lui qui l'a
déshonorée
ces crimes abominables
j'en ai cité quelques-uns parmi des
centaines ces crimes abominables
mon cher isorni c'est la france qu'il
déshonorait aux yeux du monde bien pour
se lever pour sauver ces enfants ne
croyait pas de retrouver ses enfants nus
mission avec zèle vous ne croyez mais
des jeunes femmes vous avez tendance
fâcheuse à will it later faisait son
métier
engagé ordinaire
et puis oui attendait mais je voudrais
pas réduire je vais pas je sais que vous
avez tous mais vous savez une févr
maîtrisons nouvelle année avec horreur
je parle avec monsieur teitgen et ça
n'est pas ce n'est pas une chose
c'est lui qui a posé le débat n'est pas
ou ce qui reste du débat nous avons très
bien compris votre cv très bien mettre à
jour ni
la parole à monsieur le franc le savez
que vous avez prononcé à l'assemblée
nationale écoutez
non-maîtrise journaux ou et vous avez
bien
vous les avez si bien aimé ce thème
jeunes des sections spéciales que vous
dites être une honte aujourd'hui pour la
france mais c'est que vous avez pris
comme directeur de votre cabinet
l'avocat général qui demandait des
peines devant ces sections spéciales
vous le savez ça n'est ce pas écoutez
vous fait alors là non pas vingt deux
pas ce qu'est survenu sera faire seul et
pleure parce que vous essayez de faire
dévier le débat je le ferai à ceux qui
rament les vous dira juste société
l'acteur de la france est bien blanches
et minimiser le prix n'est pas au
rendez-vous et mettre les gens du sud il
ya eu même des choses s'il faut rappeler
il vous plait il y à des centaines de
questions que les téléspectateurs qui
ont suivi avec passion tout ce que vous
avez dit voudrait nous soumettre
j'espère guitare mois que vous êtes plus
procéder à un tri et nous vous écoutons
oui il m'a fallu écarté toutes ces
fiches qui représente au moins 90 95 %
des appels et qui sont uniquement quand
dira s 10 et râle c'est de soins de
l'entousiasme soit de la haine mais
toujours des affirmations et puis il y à
des questions qui se dégage quand même
jamais retenu cinq au moins les cinq
grandes la première qu'est ce qui a pu
pousser philippe pétain couvert de
gloire et d'honneur
à 84 ans qu'est ce qui l'a poussé engagé
tout ce passé prestigieux dans l'
aventure de la défaite et de la
collaboration
deuxième question l'arrivée de pétain au
pouvoir ne représente-t-elle pas une
revanche politique sur la troisième
république et le front populaire
troisième oui troisième question
pourquoi en novembre 40 2 n'at-il pas
quitter la france
quatrième question quel était le
sentiment de la majorité de la
population à l'égard de pépin 5e mais
celles ci on en a beaucoup parlé nous
invite en ont beaucoup parlé
peut-on avec le recul du temps penser
que l'action de pétain a été utile à la
france il y avait évidemment beaucoup
d'autres questions comme celle ci que
j'ai retrouvé sur plusieurs fiches on
dit que pétain a fait ce qu'il a fait
pour sauver la france mais comment se
fait-il que même lorsque les alliés
avaient débarqué il continuer à signer
les condamnations à mort et également
beaucoup de fiches pour demander comment
la france avait pu choisir un homme
aussi ai-je
bien il a écouté guide aboient je pense
que
nous avons déjà répandu en partie à deux
questions oui on rêvait au moins deux de
ces questions peut-on avec le recul du
temps pensé que pétain à la tête du
gouvernement de vichy a été utile à la
france je crois que ce sujet a été
largement débattue et selon toute
vraisemblance nous n'arrivons pas à nous
mettre d'accord
réponse
aux pressions de la comparaison avec le
régime dans les autres pays parce que ça
c'est un argument
faudrait être plus rien justement à
l'ats par le biais de cette question
pétain et il était utile à la france on
peut tenir une comparaison avec ce qui
s'est lancée mardi à lyon comme la
belgique et notamment et le danemark
si
le danemark n'était pas en guerre avec
l'allemagne agit donc n'y a pas de
comparaison possible que la situation du
danois est celle qui ressemble le plus à
la situation de la france contrairement
ce que vous dites non parce que le
danemark avait à sa tête le roi
est à l'enfance alors que le roi de
hollande était parti alors que le roi
des belges considéré comme prisonnier
deuxièmement le dalmate a considéré que
pas plus tôt il était occupé il devait
jouer entièrement le jeu allemand vous
entendez bien il ya une région d'une
résistance danoise immédiate c'est une
légende de dalles-mères par conséquent
jouer le jeu loyal de l'occupation
allemande j'estimais qu'il ne pouvait
absolument rien faire et voilà vous
comme ans de différence
on a constitué également qu'un
gouvernement d'union nationale
on s'est bien gardé de dire tel danois
parce qu'il a fait en 1935 n'est pas
digne de faire ceci quel juif parce
qu'il est juif doit être condamné il ya
eu unanimité poursuivre le gouvernement
et pour administrer le pays au mieux
devant les exigences allemandes il y à
mieux parce que ça pétait aurait très
bien pu le faire du monde pardon rien
empêché pétain se contenter
d'administrer la france au lieu de
s'engager comme il l'a fait sans que
personne ne l'y contraint dans la
politique de collaboration car c'est lui
qui l'a voulu contrairement à ce que
vous semblez dire j'ai pas jamais hitler
qui valut à imposer il s'est engagé lui
aussi dans la politique de révolution
nationale qui a créé en france des
catégories de paria ceci ne s'est pas
fait au danemark il ya mieux
lorsque on a imposé aux dames 1
le statut des juifs
noah devant le mark addy je mettrai le
premier des toiles jaune
lorsqu'on a arrêté des juifs ces juifs
ont été arrêtés par la police allemande
par les nazis danois car il y en avait
et jamais par des policiers dany est
bienvenue le gouvernement danois et la
population danoise se sont employés en
parfait accord a évacué vers la suède
sept mille juifs danois par bateau vous
imaginez ce que ça représentait 110 3
infesté de bateau allemand et d'un fort
mieux à la fin la résultante danoise a
été tardive beaucoup plus tardive qu'en
france une à partir du moment où le
gouvernement a compris que la guerre
changé de direction et que la population
commence à en avoir assez des exigences
amende il n'a pas poursuivi la
résistance il s'est rapproché d'elle et
en définitive on a formé un comité de
libération dans lequel il y avait des
résistants clandestins et des membres du
gouvernement danois et enfin lorsque la
guerre s'est terminée au danemark elle
s'est terminée par une grève générale et
en définitive tout la police danoise a
été déporté dans un camp de
concentration
mais aucun policier danois n'avaient sur
les mains un minimum de 100 de dia je
vole que l'allemagne n'avait pas fait la
guerre au danemark il n'y avait pas
d'armistice entre le danemark et
l'allemagne il y avait une occupation à
laquelle le danemark avait consenti à
laisser ce que nous disons qu'il fallait
pas tant misé nous avions cela nous
avions même déclaré la guerre à
l'allemagne mais darwin taille que vous
avez oublié la minuad est pas
obligatoire nous l'avions déclaré la
guerre à mort vers le revenant et le
paysan
protéger l'afrique du nord et n'oubliez
pas que l'armée d'afrique
elle a été constituée par le général
weygand sur les ordres du maréchal
pétain et que c'est l'armée d'affecter
revenu victorieux elle aurait pu être
tragique à la verte au nom et au nom de
l'art que les allemands seraient arrivés
en a encore vous oubliez unis sont venus
les appuyer
mais vous oubliez un aspect de la
collaboration car on a parlé jusqu'ici
de la collaboration policière qui l'a
plus on a fait allusion à la
collaboration économique est forte at il
même ajouté un mot c'est que si vous les
verrez donc moi je vous conseille de
lire mais vous verrez par exemple le
rapport du docteur michel qui était le
chef elle mord michel luc était le chef
de l'économie de service de l'économie
aux militaires de tiago in frankreich en
commun comme non militaire à paris et le
dr michel son rapport est à votre
disposition
bien que grâce aux autorités françaises
grâce à la coopération montré par les
autorités françaises la france a donné
beaucoup plus proportionnellement à ce
qu'on donnait tous les autres pays tous
les chantiers navals amiral tous les
chantiers navals ont travaillé à 100%
pour notre français
tout allait bien je voulais chanter pour
le port les bateaux allemands robin a
tout dirigé toutes les usines
aéronautiques ont travaillé pour
l'allemand on a fabriqué aujourd'hui
qu'en 1940 2 on a fabriqué 4500 avion
pour les allemands on a fabriqué 11000
moteur passe comme ça c'est la
collaboration économique il faut de dire
un bond de la collaboration militaire
est souvent la question l'ensemble parce
que la collaboration en interne il devra
arriver jusqu'en 1 q que le maréchal ne
voulait pas j'ai convaincu de ce qu'il
voulait c'était la neutralité alors je
suis même convaincu aussi mais
précisément j'y arrive je suis même
convaincu que le président laval ne
voulait pas quand il a rencontré hitler
à montoire et david maréchal ne peut pas
déclarer la guerre et c'est pour ça mais
regarde ton avis mais parce qu'on est là
on ne met pas connectés dans les jt mais
parce qu'on était dans le regard et la
gare 11 mai parce qu'on était dans
l'invention d'accord d'accord à
parler de la syrie
c'est monsieur lefranc qui était mon
interlocuteur excusé par conséquent le
maréchal pétain et le président la balle
ne voulait certainement pas déclaré la
guerre à l'angleterre europe monsieur
pearson est de mon avis sur ce point
l'amiral darlan c'est tout autre chose
je peux la mire attendant c'est tout
autre chose en ce qui concerne d'anvers
des alliances et d'une fête du fait que
la france n'était plus du fait que la
france était dans une convention
d'armistice qui faisait que la moitié de
son territoire était occupée la france
n'était plus neutre elle n'était plus
neutre parce que ces ouvriers travailler
pour les usines allemandes parce qu'on a
envoyé en allemagne non pas cinq cent
mille travailleurs mais 800 milles et
vincent bilodeau qui travaillent en
france elle n'était plus libre parce
qu'elle payer une indemnité d'occupation
qui permettait aux allemands d'acheter
les communes françaises elles n'étaient
plus neutre parce que les soldats les
miliciens de de pétain ont chassé des
résistants français et parce que les
régions de renseignement été livré aux
policiers aux policiers allemands et
adore la coban la collaboration
militaire mais ce qui est arrivé est cet
empire dont vous dites qu'on l'a
réservée pour en 1942 le mettre dans la
lutte mais m is honey vous n'avez pas
entendu parler des protocoles de paris
si vous n'entendez pas comme on nous l'a
par le bas mais je vais vous dire ma
vérité alors je le caresse je m'éteins
les hug thermique bombay les protocoles
et d'arlon les avait signé les parents
les avaient proposé bon perle pour les
btan les arranger votre col de paris se
sont ils avaient trois parties dans des
protocoles de paris
la première en syrie a été exécuté ou
des gta son cabinet ce n'est pas très
précisément elle avec des buts il répond
ce dernier elle a discuté pleinement la
deuxième à bizerte a reçu un
commencement d'exécution c'est à dire
que nous avons livré aux allemands et si
ça c'est pas de la collaboration
militaire comment appelez-vous la
possibilité de passer par le port de
bizerte la possibilité de passer par les
eaux territoriales tunisiennes nous
avons été bons nous avons livré des
camions la troisième partie qui n'a pas
été appliquée c'est serge gaillard
général de serigne l'allemagne demandé
un poste ont lieu la nuit en or il a en
effet déjà cher si le protocole de paris
n'ont pas été appliquées
c'est évidemment d'abord parce que le
général weygand et le gouverneur général
boissons s'y sont opposés mais on est
revenu quelques mois passent dans ces
protocoles de paris c'est ce que vous ne
dites pas on y revient au roman
jamais revu ce moment où l'armée romaine
est arrivé un conte frontières gélatine
mais bien sûr mais vous parlez de choses
que vous me connaissez
termites mois d'affilée de des locaux
une phrase j'ai les accords de paris des
protocoles de paris n'ont pas été
appliquées c'est que en définitive c'est
hitler qui n'a pas voulu qu'on aille
plus loin et qu'on n'a pas voulu mais
monsieur religieux apprenons logique de
la guerre et vous comprendrez l'isba
était on n'a pas voulu qu'on allait plus
loin parce que contrairement à ce que
vous avez dit les problèmes
méditerranéens n'ont jamais intéressé
hitler l'espace vital c'est une union
soviétique qu'il recherchait et à tenter
le moment où il est entré en guerre
contre l'union soviétique des problèmes
méditerranéen de ne plus intéresser du
tout at il des parts et en ukraine et en
grèce et quand il débarquait en train
d'errer sittler ça ne m'intéressait pas
la méditerranée ils ont mis m je vous en
prie monsieur girard qui était au
cabinet du maréchal pétain peut même
apporter une précision quelque chose et
des questions tout à l'heure en disant
il ya eu des morts c'est affreux procès
très bien mais ça peut plus d'accord on
ne fait pas la guerre sans qu'il y ait
des morts et le maréchal pétain
faisaient la guerre et c'est parce que
c'était un homme de guerre il veut
contre qui ça fait nouveau contre
l'allemagne essieux un arrêt chez moi
parler et vous expliquer à mon retour là
les choses car vous nous parlez beaucoup
de la collaboration franco allemande
c'est un fait je ne nie pas et le
maréchal quinze jours avant mon toit
rouge soir on a prononcé deux discours
c'est le 10 et le 11 octobre dans
lesquelles il est i
kill ce qu'il s'apprêtait à faire une
politique de collaboration
internationale et celle où
internationale qui doit retenir votre
attention sur laquelle il allait édifier
sa politique celle dont il vous dira
qu'elle est la sienne parce qu'elle en a
tiré sans rien c'est très intéressant la
figurez vous que je vais vous
l'expliquer
d'un monde un mot je voudrais revenir
encore assauts sempiternelles armistice
les choses sont beaucoup plus
compliquées vous l'imaginez car en
réalité le premier qui a parlé
d'armistice année par monsieur pétole ça
n'est pas monsieur weygand c'est
monsieur lebrun et vous et vous le savez
c'est pour la peine d'insister là dessus
puisque vous savez que c'est au comité
secret du 25 mai qu'il en a parlé pour
la première fois que vous ne savez pas
c'est pourquoi monsieur lebrun en a
parlé et ça c'est beaucoup plus curieux
c'est parce que monsieur
hyper à travers monsieur göring je lui
avais fait dire avait fait venir à
monsieur paul reynaud
que l'allemagne était prête à consentir
un armistice à paul reynaud et c'est
paul reynaud qui à partir de ce moment
là va essayer de se dérober à
l'armistice qu'il ne veut pas signer
parce qu'il est lié avec le cherche il
quand vous le savez et tout ça vient de
choses beaucoup plus compliquée encore
c'est qu'il ya derrière tout cela la
politique tant de l'allemagne que dès
que des alliés et il y assure tout se
fait que l'allemagne n'a jamais entendu
faire la guerre à l'angleterre
l'allemagne
ça peut vous surprendre mais sept
médecins dans les tous les
surprendre et à l'air monsieur hitler
est un monsieur qui espérait
espérer faire la guerre à la russie et
conquérir l'empiré l'est dont vous
parliez vous a fait des confidences
suite les omeyyades une aussi là dessus
sur scène et alors monsieur monsieur
monsieur hitler a toujours espéré que
les engrais ne lui ferait pas la guerre
il a été très déçu de voir les anglais
lui faire la guerre en 1939 et la france
lui faire la guerre dans le sillage de
l'angleterre et il a essayé d séparées
l'une de l'autre
ça c'était que ça assez curieux
il a vers un point il a payé
mais pas grasse a fait tapis ce que ces
deux là c'est à paul reynaud qui passe
un armistice et nous avions eu si nous
avions eu à les éléments pour alimenter
la fran ais côté les services et moi
laissez moi
s'il vous plaît monsieur ça devient
gênant
non ce qui se passe si
vous voulez vous dans le prolongement
wine et dire dire ce dia ce qui a poussé
le maréchal mais c'est le shérif jamais
j'arrive c'est excessivement basse et de
rentabiliser précisément va c'est
précisément parce que la france et
l'angleterre se trouve séparer du fait
au moment de l'armistice que
l'angleterre
abcès pts de l'armistice car monsieur
churchill à tours a accepté armistice et
qui se sont mis d'accord là avec le
gouvernement français a considéré qu'il
pouvait s'engager sur la voie de la
mitis ne revenons pas sur toutes les
tenues en tout et que progrès notamment
des danses tout ça est à sa façon de
celle connue maintenant et ça n'est pas
des pages brillantes pour monsieur paul
reynaud par contre ce qui est vrai ni
pour pétain mais vous monsieur pédales a
rien à se reprocher dans cette
affaire-là et alors je vais vous
expliquer ce qui est arrivé à pétain et
vous allez voir que je n'oublie pas les
les questions que nous avons à traiter
c'est celle ci c'est que au moment
où après votre comité de guerre du 25
mai quand monsieur lebrun a parlé pour
la première fois de l'armistice ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que le lendemain de le
lendemain monsieur chautemps vice
président du conseil appelé monsieur
baudouin pour lui dire maintenant il
nous faut un gouvernement car paul
raynaud ne veut pas faire l'armistice il
nous faut un gouvernement et leurs coms
nous voulons par ce soit weygand qui est
un affreux réactionnaire nous voulons
que ce soit [ __ ] cette année les mots
crac on parle de l'armistice challenge
se battre et d'autres vous n'avez pas
parlé dash-8 l'histoire
et oui déjà millions de comptes je
voudrais savoir parce que je pense que
j'ai été invité à cette réunion en
raison du rôle que j'ai joué
comme avocat je voudrais savoir si on a
l'intention de parler du procès même du
maréchal absolument pas absolument pas
qu'il n'était pas question de riz alors
les avancées ne s'agit pas de refaire le
procès mais j'aurais tout de même voulu
aller et voilà ce que je suis alors la
question c'est pourquoi le marché de
l'art c'est la réponse est non
oui alors là le fait de l'avoir mis dans
une vous m'avez fait dire pour ça parce
que j'avais des choses graves à dire sur
les conditions dans lequel le maréchal
pétain a été condamné c'est tout de même
quelque chose de très important le chef
de l'état soit condamné à mort à votre
demande monsieur telus elle non cher
monsieur
je n'ai donné aucune instruction à
personne mais vous avez un chef du
ministère public oui mais vous savez
bien que je n'ai donné aucune
instruction ou le savez pas fait de
maître nous avons une règle dans cette
émission c'est de tenir compte des
questions des téléspectateurs
alors alors monsieur freiner répondez à
cette question
là y est je pense d'abord à s'y
attendait la question qui a été posée
par l'un téléspectateurs ça veut dire
est ce que l'action du général du
maréchal pétain a été utile ou non à la
population valence et bien à mes yeux il
ya une responsabilité écrasante
avant d'en venir au procès si on en
haletant qui n'a pas été évoqué les
responsabilités écrasantes
c'est le maréchal pétain en raison de
son prestige en raison de l'immense
popularité a égaré une masse
d'excellents français qui l'ont suivi
non pas dans ce soi-disant double jeu
dont on parlait et dont il était bien
entendu à supposer qu'il ait existé
impossible qu'ils montrent les deux
faces il ne pouvait donc en montrer
qu'une et je le connais par la premier
et il a égaré les français dans les
conditions que je voudrais rappeler
lorsque la lorsque la légion française
des combattants et volontaires français
contre le bolchevisme
a été constituée
le maréchal pétain à encourager les
français à s'y engager il a envoyé un
message on connaît la bonne publicité
dans votre livre m et dans lesquels il
dit vous détenez une part de notre
honneur militaire en participant à cette
croisade dont l'allemagne a pris la tête
vous acquérez de juste titre à la
reconnaissance du monde
lorsque mois d'avril 1942
il rappelle laval au pouvoir
après avoir dit que c'était une
catastrophe ils
rappellent quand même laval dit vous le
savez je souhaite la victoire allemande
et que dit qu'elle est que dit quelques
jours plus tard le maréchal pétain
ce gouvernement nouveau vous donne de
nouvelles raisons de croire et d'espérer
transformer lorsqu'en novembre
1942 outre alstom et les gens l'afrique
d'une année plus visible figure là qui
préfigure une partie de la libération il
donne des ordres à trois reprises
différentes malgré un grand cafouillage
aux troupes françaises vous devez lutter
jusqu'à l'extrême limite de vos forces
aux travailleurs qui sont partis en
allemagne aux travailleurs qui sont
partis en allemagne il s'adresse à eux
de ce ton paternel qu'il prendrait si
volontiers en 10 ans loin de vos foyers
vous travaillez encore pour la france
dans la lèvre de faim 43 mètres que vous
citiez il ya une phrase que vous n'êtes
pas cités il disait à hitler par la
lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est à dire contre nous mêmes par la
lutte contre le terrorisme et le
communisme elle contribue à la défense
de la civilisation occidentale
et on fait en avril 1944 il s'adressait
à la population disait en 10 ans
français quiconque participe au
groupement de résistance compromet
l'avenir du pays il rendait hommage à
l'allemagne de sa défense du continent
de très grands français l'ont suivi je
voudrais citer un exemple personnel en
1942 ma mère ma mère
pensant que je m'étais engagé dans la
résistance en quoi elle se trompait pas
parce qu'elle respectait le maréchal
pétain parce qu'elle avoir confiance en
lui estimait qu'il était un devoir de me
dénoncer à la police et si possible de
me faire arrêter le maréchal pétain a
été suivi par des hommes qui la menait
tout droit au peloton d'exécution
un homme comme joseph darnand par
exemple qui me faisait demander à moi
même par l'intermédiaire de nos
camarades à toulon au lendemain du
sabordage de la flotte c était possible
de passer en angleterre
je le dis non c'est trop tard vous avez
été trop loin il faudra être allé
jusqu'au bout et il y a été et ce même
joseph darnand a créé la milice à la
tête d'une troupe qui a fait l'effort
fait que nous connaissons et il a été
exécuté par les pelotons d'exécution de
la libération et capitaine bassompierre
qui a écouté et petacchi lui disait vous
donne une part notre honneur militaire
en participant à cette croisade vous
accusez vous avez dû attirer des titres
à la reconnaissance du monde il a été
levé à un peloton d'exécution
il a égaré la france dont le devoir
était tout simple il était allait être
résisté elle dans l' empêcher ça c'est
des responsables majeurs à mon avis
quand rien excuses que rien ne pardonne
et vous croyez que ceux qui ont fait
fusiller bassompierre n'ont pas pris
aussi de lourdes responsabilités en
1947 un homme qui avait été beaucoup de
respect pour les hommes qui mettent leur
peau au bout de leurs idées oui j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour eux elle me
serait découvert au moment du peloton
d'exécution
il avait combattu contre nous tous ce
que vous dites ne change rien à ce que
j'ai essayé d'expliquer car vous ne
pouvez tout de même pas vous y aviez
qu'avait une mère qui a eu le grand
respect du maréchal vous ne pouvez tout
de même pas douter des intentions qui
étaient les siennes m vous croyez vous
voulez faire tuer des gens ils voulaient
les mais j'ai alors mais vous attendez
vous à votre vous rendiez qu'il était en
présence de l'occupation la plus dure à
bord de la mer en pleine ascension ne
lui tend pas la main mais un instant de
c'était pour sauver ya d'autres choses
qui lui a tendu la main et vous oubliez
ce qu'on dit il sort également que
montois avaient été faites pour une
plaie sorny que intentions est ce que
vous avez lu le compte rendu de noeux
l'entrevue c'est ma vous dit
l'interprète d'hitler et dix ans le
vainqueur séné pétain je demande à
monsieur je me suis je ne savais pas ne
faut pas parler de la collaboration et
clame messieurs
s'il vous plaît je vous les intentions
d'un homme d'état m'intéresse peu un
homme d'état ne se juge pas son
intention il se juge sur ses actes eh
bien les agrumes et à le condamne à
l'étude on dirait aujourd'hui mais très
gentils messieurs s'il vous plaît une
miraculeuse réussite vous avez dit que
berlin le retrait dans dix ans vous
plaît monsieur girard jeunes ont appris
être journée je vous dis solennellement
à tous que si le débat doit continuer à
se dérouler dans une telle confusion je
vais être obligé de l'interrompre étant
donné d'autre part l'heure qu'il est
alors revenons si vous voulez vos
questions dt le pardon sur la protection
je voudrais que nous
revenons au problème mais nous avons à
vienne où il avait des accents anglais
et les américains je voudrais pour rien
au procès du maréchal alors à venir
moi j'ai connu le maréchal pétain en
prison vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
comme en football alors je tiens bon tu
nous as jazz et des jours près sérieuse
à dire eh bien nous avons des questions
de téléspectateurs au crédit n'a pas été
répondu monsieur girard avait commencé
qu'est ce qui a poussé le maréchal
pétain à assumer les responsabilités qui
l'a acceptée en 1940 la question
subsidiaire et en est ce que comme
beaucoup l'ont dit ça n'était pas pour
lui et pour son entourage une revanche
sur la troisième république ne le feront
pas l'huma pas alors monsieur girard
vous répondrez hasselhoff vrai problème
pour le maréchal et qu'à partir de
l'armistice
qu'il avait accepté à bordeaux les
anglais eux ont
poursuivi la guerre ce qui était
inattendu dans l'esprit non mais oui
mais oui
nous sommes seuls à l'apparenté c'est
que vous c'est que vous ne semblez pas
connaître la position diplomatique des
de l'angleterre et des états unis à ce
moment là le championnat reste de la
guerre il n'a dit l'arrêt pas il a été
sur le point de se retirer de la faim
devant à parce que ce ministre qui était
prêt à demander la paix je dirais la
paix d'amiens pour que mon commentaire
la paix d'amiens à hitler il ya renoncé
monsieur j'irai parce que la mairie a
donné à l'angleterre 1 promis à
l'angleterre un concours que l'amérique
avait refusé à la france quelques jours
plus tôt à voulez vous avoir la
gentillesse de répondre à la question
qu'est ce qui a poussé le maréchal
pétain à assumer les responsabilités qui
l'a acceptée en 1940 msv ce sont les
nécessités et les hommes politiques
français les hommes politiques français
quelques précisions apporte quoi ils
formaient sausset soyez courageux vrai
qu'on l'ennuie donc vous oubliez eux du
moins je rappelle qu'au moment de la
défaite mais feint d'être ambassadeur de
france à madrid c'est paul reynaud qui
l'a fait venir et qu'il a nommé
vice président du conseil en même temps
qu'il appelait quelques temps après au
pouvoir le général de gaulle c'est paul
reynaud qui a réuni le maréchal pétain
et le général de gaulle il est vrai et
je sais qu'il a dit tout à l'heure que
pétain a voulu tout de suite l'armistice
c'est vrai je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi on nous a dit plus on nous a
montré tout à l'heure
on leur montrait tout à l'heure la
guerre
1914-1918 pétain dont on a dit qu'il
était là défi la défensive ce n'est pas
exact des teintes et la défensive quand
il avait les moyens de la défensive pour
préparer l'offensive
lorsqu'il le fallait et lorsque foch a
conclu les pourparlers d'armistice
le 11 novembre 1910
1118 pétain est venu c'est une chose qui
peut connue dans l'histoire de france
mettait une réalité tu es maintenant
incontestable il ému supplier
le maréchal foch de ne pas faire
l'armistice parce qu'il était prévue
pour trois jours après une offensive
générale vous le savez monsieur freinet
qui devait mener les troupes françaises
sous le commandement de castelnau au
coeur de l'allemagne et pétain a pleuré
devant foch en pensant que c'était une
erreur terrible erreur terrible d'où est
sorti d'ailleurs la guerre de 1939 pépin
s'est inclinée mais il a toujours
ressenti comme une victoire de
l'allemagne là
l'armistice accordé prématurément à
l'allemagne et si bien que lorsqu'il a
été au pouvoir
par le fait de paul reynaud il a tout de
suite eu le souvenir qu'il avait marqué
toute sa vie mais si je fais l'armistice
le plus tôt possible avec l'allemagne ce
sera cette défaite de la france des
faits réels des armes va devenir une
victoire estelle épices son état
d'esprit était là et et sa détermination
et il a pensé que c'était par cet
artiste d'ailleurs qu'ils pouvaient
préserver les valeurs essentielles de la
france voilà pourquoi non m alors si
nous remontons jusqu'en 1918 mais il ne
faut rien laisser dans leur expliquer
non non attendez le 25 mars 1918 c'est
monsieur loucheur qui raconte ses
mémoires monsieur le seul ou soeurs et
ministre de l'armement à l'époque le
main le général pétain lui a dit je suis
très inquiet il faut demander à
clemenceau de solliciter la paix dans
l'honneur car les russes nous ont lâchés
les américains tarde à venir je n'ai
plus le réserve nous allons être battu
il faut évacuer paris en mars 1918
loucheur dans ses mémoires il n'y a pas
eu de démenti que je sache
des matisse est un mode loucheur montée
du tapis c'est rarissime des armes ne
renseigne qui les a conduites à lelystad
art je ne vois pas trop croire ce
capital et kim a man who laval je ne
pense pas qu'il faille remonter je leur
explique deschamps car le pétain 40 le
medad 40 à 44
exactement le même pétain que de 1916
alors 200 m selon la demande je vous
comprends très bien selon vous heatley a
demandé leur mise 6 pour que cet
armistice soit une suspension tarn et
pour que le moment venu on puisse
reprendre le combat c'est bien ça vous
avez dit non non non vécu je n'ai pas
compétent a sollicité l'armistice pas
plus pour que celui ci soit une
suspension d'armes oui car moment donné
on puisse reprendre le combat
eh bien il n'a pas demandé l'asile à
noter la paix il n'a pas des navets et
landry l'a fait mes rêves mais mélanie
la tête comme cet essai de vous avez
quand même que je publie serré mais non
mais je suis très grande vitesse qui ne
s'est pas demandé avec les journées il a
demandé mais on est un terreau c'est
comme la trisomie ne connaît jamais je
suis un peu dans
les prés nous ne pouvons pas continuer
ce dialogue à plusieurs le
téléspectateur ne comprend strictement
plus rien et d'une 5e martin o'neill
météo vent alors mais les journées soit
hurlantes et cherchais ma démonstration
soyez brefs mais je suis très vrai mais
c'est comme ça mais c'est capital parce
que depuis un sacré moment on dit que
leur métier c'était une véritable
victoire or l'armistice des français
péter en tête ne voulaient pas ce qu'il
met ce qu'il voulait c'était la paix et
la chose est tout à fait capitale
quasiment
s'il vous plaît parce qu'à partir du
moment ont demandé la paix c'est qu'on
ne voulait plus après n'envisageait plus
dur commence et jamais le combat et cela
nous le savons de façon absolument
certain monsieur je vous renvoie aux
documents diplomatiques également parce
que nous le savons parce que monsieur
paul baudoin après bien sûr comme tout
ce que joue un rôle à ce moment a essayé
dans ses mémoires de se mettre dans une
position qui était la plus brillante
pour lui aurait score il a dit qu'il
avait demandé un armistice mais nous
savons qu'il a demandé par l'ambassadeur
d'espagne qui s'est adressée à
l'ambassadeur du rail à madrid et nous
savons par cet ambassadeur du rage qu'il
a demandé les conditions de paix cet
ambassadeur lui a fait répéter c'est
l'armistice une situation semble que
vous voulez ou la paix et on a répondu
la paix et lorsque le général de giguère
s'est trouvé ensuite à rotonde et qu'il
a téléphoné au général weygand qu'est-ce
qui lui a dit m vous ne le savez pas eh
bien il lui a dit je le regrette
beaucoup mais je n'ai pas pu savoir
quelles étaient les conditions de paix
par conséquent c'est la tchèque au
regard et c'est la paix cauris qui le
prouve une richesse et honnêtes les
contient essaiera d une suspension
d'arbres déjà c'est capital parce que ça
démoule est entièrement vos
argumentations bien je suis désolé
monsieur le franc avait demandé le
premier la parole est ensuite ce sera
monsieur tel-jeunes qu'ils avaient
le croyait des gens ensuite avait
ensuite avoué amiral oui j'ai été
frappée en revoyant certains passages de
ce film par cette phrase terrible que
prononce pétain 1944 n'est ce pas alors
que le monde entier est en guerre alors
que les armées alliées ont abordé le
continent européen et pétain dit surtout
ne vous mêlez pas de la guerre français
surtout ce n'est pas votre affaire
comment ça n'était pas notre affaire ça
faisait quatre ans qu'on était occupée
ça faisait quatre années que les
familles françaises étaient dispersés
que la france était mis aux pillages et
pétain vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure ba
déclarent aux français ne vous
intéressez pas la guerre salue pas votre
affaire alors comment peut-on penser et
déclaré qu'en demandant l'investissent
péta penser à la suite quand il a
déclaré ça devant tout le monde c'est
absolument impossible
monsieur le professeur avec votre
permission est ce que vous m'autorisez a
donné la parole à monsieur vendre l
usine qui n'a pas pris la parole depuis
le début de cette émission monsieur
paxton auzines souhaiterait s'exprimer
alors monsieur votre musée j'ai appelé
mais je voudrais être très bref pour
apporter peut être deux précisions sur
deux points que le débat a abordé et
dans l'ordre chronologique
je commencerai par la question de la
paix parce que effectivement il faut se
rappeler que notre gouvernement avait
rejoint la france et avait vécu les
vicissitudes du gouvernement français et
avait décidé moment donné au final du
gouvernement louis et avait décidé avant
de finalement gagner l'angleterre
d'adopter la même attitude que la france
est dans les démarches qu'il fait à ce
moment là il ya aussi des questions qui
sont posées au sujet d'une négociation
de belles éventuelles et ça précisément
parce que le pays qui sert de référence
dans l'attitude à ce moment là des
ministres belge et la france défaite
alors je veux je voulais reprendre un
autre point antérieure du débat et qui
consiste à comparer la situation ou
belgique et en france lula je peux être
extrêmement bref en belgique il s'est
passé comme dans tous les pays qui ont
été soulevées desalmand une série d'
abomination mais on pouvait toujours
dire que ce qui se faisait dabo mineur
était voulue par les allemands et que
les agents d'exécution était soit les
allemands soit les collaborateurs belges
mais là il n'y avait aucune équivoque
possible et c'était clair et c'est net
voilà très vives alors attendez
maintenant vers monsieur paxton m'a
demandé la parole depuis un grand moment
là même monsieur paxton vous ai je le
rappelle un historien américain et je
voudrais cas c'est pour cela aussi tout
semble qu'il soit répondu à une question
posée par de nombreux téléspectateurs
est-ce que la prise du pouvoir par le
maréchal pétain et son entourage en juin
1940 est aussi une revanche sur la
troisième république et sur le front
populaire est ce que vous voulez
répondre à cette question oui ces
histoires le point auquel vous lui vaut
venir parce que
ses dix avions capital à
connaître la politique allemande à ce
moment-là et
maître isorni a parlé tout à l'heure
comme si les exigences alors on dédie
continue
complète infinie tandis que au
commencement en joie en juillet en août
le gouvernement allemand n'avait pas
encore fixé une position envers la
politique intérieure de la france il y
avait deux choses qui intéressent et les
allemands au moment de l'armistice la
sécurité des troupes et le butin de
guerre eh bien il n'y avait pas eu
d'exigence allemand du tout en juin
juillet août en ce qui concerne la
politique intérieure dans la france
forme du gouvernement la politique
scolaire politique envers les juifs
aussi au moment
de la loi du 4 octobre 140 sur les juifs
il n'y avait aucune exigence allemande
du tout ce sujet était une initiative
purement française
et ne faisait pas suite à une exigence
allemande il serait utile
aussi
une seule capitale juqu'à aussi à
savoir pourquoi seul de tous les pays
occupés de l'ouest la france n'a pas pu
se limiter aux origines de simples jets
ans au lieu de deux procédés tout de
suite à une révolution nationale c'est à
dire transformer les valeurs et les
astuces française
au moment même quand les armées
allemandes étaient là il serait utile
aussi à comparer
le sort des français
au sort des autres peuples en europe est
rendu et parce que autant que je le
sache
aucune des exigences
n'a été épargné aux français plus tard
la stéréo par exemple ça a commencé en
france à peu près le même moment
d'ailleurs au moment au printemps 2009
140 heures où les allemands au change et
politique de guerre pour faire la guerre
totale
ses exigences au matériel et aux
manoeuvres ont été imposées
simultanément
en hollande en belgique en france sans
que
l'ex n a pas été mieux traités que les
autres pays
oui voudraient je crois que ça
intéressera aussi tous les spectateurs
je voudrais répondre monsieur freiner
qui a mis à charge du maréchal sa
position 9 ans 42 et je voudrais aussi
dire à monsieur paxton sur ce point ne
sommes pas du tout d'accord
le maréchal pétain pour ne pas tomber
dans une dénonciation de l'armistice
cessez-le-feu de la mi temps les
allemands n'ont jamais ouvert le feu ils
ont violé une des clauses géographique
de l'armistice une clause important
d'une clause essentielle en en pénétrant
dans la ligne de démarcation
mais l'as lorraine n'oubliez pas mais
malgré ce raid c'est pareil et non pas
le cessez-le-feu
s'est maintenue c'est ça l'essentiel du
donneur beasty c'est ça que ça veut dire
laissez moi parler monsieur
on a mis à la charge du maréchal pétain
sa position en europe 42 ya une position
officielle faite pour éviter justement
la rupture d'armistice mais il ya eu une
position officielle par en dessous et
alors là monsieur paxton il ya un ou
deux qui est un menteur parce que vous
dire absolument de tap télégramme que
j'ai envoyé
de la part du maréchal pétain à l'amiral
darlan est existait alors je suis témoin
il ya des témoins il ya eu des procès il
ya eu le procès du maréchal dans le
temps non chaque jour il fait moins ceux
qui m'ont aidé à chiffrer c'était les
grades qui vivent toujours il m'écoutait
l'a peut-être même dans cette salle
n'est ce pas alors je demande de sur ce
point tout peut débit c'est de la
littérature c'est très important
contraire ça qui ne sait pas s'il faut
nier elle était le contenu des
télégrammes d'un rendement pour
melbourne ont ensuite bien le pense
qu'ils et oui je me suis peu je
m'exprime trop vite tellement j'ai peu
de temps n'est ce pas par des
télégrammes officiels envoyés soit en
plaire soit dans des peuples de procéder
les allemands ont indiqué à l'armée
d'afrique de continuer mais par en
dessous
le maréchal pétain a envoyé quatre
télégramme l'amiral darlan qui était une
suite j'ai quelques papiers qui d'abord
lui montrer sa confiance qu'ils ont dit
on ne vous a retiré le commandement chef
de renommée était peu parce que on ne
vous preniez prisonniers et puis le
dernier délire apq est capital que du 13
novembre a peur un type du maréchal
pétain et du général
oui alors monsieur paxton ici par
exemple dit tout ça c'est de la
littérature
alors je dis il ya un ou deux qui est un
menteur bon alors voilà michel bissonnet
est mis en cause
alors vous voulez que monsieur michel
répondre à votre place non je n'ai que
faire du bien
aux mômes en conséquence et élégant
apparemment non j'ai mes oreilles bons
aux moment que le maréchal a envoyé vous
avez envoyé un télégramme à la merde
alors qu'elle était la politique de la
mère d'hamlet cette politique n'était
pas rentré on compare aux côtés des
alliés il faut il faut périodes is est
très soigneusement il a passé une
période d'une semaine il une semaine
pendant laquelle l'année à dallas a
voulu garder la neutralité de l'afrique
du nord et si cette politique la
majorité a approuvé
mais pardon je veux je peux vous
répondre en 48 heures va maintenant
retourner le combat nous partions d'une
position d'hostilité contre les
américains hostilités fatale puisque
nous n'étions pas prévenus vous
américain où l'ambassadeur américain
joshua fattal en pouvant vert
pouvait se taire en général on ne coule
pas les attaquer j'ai dit
que nous n'étions pas prévenus de la
tête américaine que même l'ambassadeur
américain à vichy mister tech nous avait
trompés en me disant de rentrer en
afrique sans boue bas le premier
militaire français qui est on bien en
afrique c'est un malheureux
fonctionnaires devant le fort d'un jeu à
1h20 du matin avant tout les deux
messages de bon darlan a mis deux jours
à rôtir à se retourner ton et sa mère
a retourné sa veste alors nous irons là
bas si vous voulez mais nous sommes dans
le bon sens quoi parlent les vestes et
toujours ça
puis on l'appelle à qui on
l'a fait à sa fille mais oui oui oui il
faut le dire au monde et ce sont des
jours tragiques que j'ai vécu des mois
je dois être à mon âge il faut
parce que vraiment quand on est un jeune
homme qui avait huit ans sur 240 est
sous mandât bien séduire sans revenir à
l'iran
alors que l'amiral comme jamais de temps
d'être acquis pendant le télégramme de
l'accord un type a été envoyée le 13
novembre en réponse à un message de nos
galeries lui disant
je vous propose de nommer de l'amiral
darlan à n'ouvrir etc et est de couvrir
l'arrangement avec les américains donc
non et non mais c'est capital côté jeux
de mots ce que vous avez vous êtes les
intellectuels n'ont jamais sont
parrainés ans le jour même mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ça je savais très bien
ce qu'ils avaient au bout depuis vous
savez pas faire la guerre
on l'a fait on la gagne
s'il vous plaît monsieur dont elle seule
a la parole le mur a logiquement non à
dire aujourd'hui tout s'est tu aimeras
je suis navré de ce navet que vous y
était mis en cause de cette façon car
s'il ya quelqu'un qui en novembre 40 2 à
vichy ne mérite absolument aucun euro
plonge ses nous lui
envoyer mais moi seule manche à la nage
en 35 matches nous sommes bien d'accord
mais c'est vous seul vous avez écrit
rajon cadre d'accords avec le marchand
vous avez les cousins du sud accord avec
le maréchal mais vous ne savez pas tout
je peux avoir votre livre jaune renvoie
votre livre vous aviez file direct avec
l'amirauté alger et vous vous allez bien
servi je dis tout de suite ce que vous
n'avez pas su vous ne l'expliqué pas
dans votre livre c'est qu'au même moment
où vous envoyer ce télégramme à l'amiral
darlan sur le centre duquel je
reviendrai pas ce que vous lui donnez
que la critique ne lui donne pas un
témoin peut être emporté par ses
souvenirs la critique historique a pour
mission d'utiliser des documents leur
donnait dans une étape d'importance et
bien au même moment ce que vous ne
saviez pas c'est que le maréchal pétain
commander aux troupes de tunisie de se
battre quand on les amériques je ne
savais pas de sauvetage n'ont même
jamais mais ça c'était pas dans les
bonnes au moment
même où s'était finie c'était fini au
maroc et en algérie non seulement ce
télégramme nous disait pas l'amiral
darlan qu'ils devaient se mettre du côté
des américains mais il recommandait aux
français qui ne s'était pas encore battu
en tunisie'' de se battre contre les
américains et c'est ce qui a fait que la
campagne de tunisie a duré six mois et
que la libération de la france était un
sirop table et je n'arrive à votre
véritable cachet d'accord avec vous
c'est capital et leveaux et qu'on fasse
une lecture une lecture 20g vous qui n'a
pas eu beaucoup de bruits hélas ce livre
de monsieur pierre d'air ce regard
nouveau sur des années 40 livres de
monsieur pierre terre ah oui monsieur
perdez vous voyez les gens perdent est
épris monsieur perdait c'était à la
commission parlementaire enquête les
télégrammes ont été publiés dans le
rapport de la commission parlementaire
enquête et j'arrive à votre télégramme
fameux
quart ce qui est important c'est le
savoir à quoi vous répondre et quelle
est la situation
quand d'autres télégrammes arrive à
alger voilà tout le problème parce que
nous sommes dans 48 heures 48 heures si
court mais dense et 48 heures et se
passer énormément de choses et à vichy
vous n'aviez que de lumière imparfaite
et quand vous répondez au télégramme
j'espère d'être clair c'est une affaire
très compliquée quand vous répondez au
télégramme accords intimes vous citez
dans votre télégramme le numéro du
télégramme que vous avez reçu du général
noguès vous l'avez très bien expliqué
c'est exactement comme ça qu'ils se
présentent c'est à dire que le général
noguès dit je demande qu'on redonne à
l'amiral darlan les pouvoirs qui étaient
les siens puisque maintenant il est
libre il est en train de discuter avec
les américains qu'il est libéré qui
l'ont libérée se demande qu'il continue
c'est à ça que vous répondez et pas
autre chose parce que ira mais amiral
laissez moi je mets la soirée à l'issue
de la peau fait on des six mois parce
qu'à ce moment vous ne savez pas que
d'amiral comme on a dit à retourner sa
veste et vous ne pouvez pas le savoir et
vous ne pouvez pas savoir mais c'est pas
vous qui êtes en cause de mieux vous ne
pouvez pas savoir pourquoi parce que
c'est au moment où le télégramme
parvient à g que déjà avant de l'avoir
reçue d'arles en a décidé de retourner
sa veste par conséquent l'accord intime
il n'est pas donné à ses environs il
peut se faire que dans son for intérieur
le maréchal pétain et penser que tout
compte fait il valait mieux que
l'afrique du nord rentrer dans la guerre
moi je n'ai jamais fait du maréchal
pétain l'ombre aux allemands il s'est
trouvé pris dans une terrible terrible
engrenage ce que je ne comprends pas ce
qu'on ne fasse pas la part des choses
d'une façon plus précise mais je n'aurai
pas du tout un partisan de l'allemagne
il ne l'était pas par conséquent le
revirement de l'amiral darlan
concrètement est-ce que vous avez créés
en toute bonne foi à vichy il n'a pas
été provoqué par votre télégramme il
s'est produit avant il se produira donc
pourquoi pour une raison bien simple
c'est que des amériques appuyé par hiro
et les dissidents ont effectué une telle
pression sur d'arlon et que l'opinion
publique avait commencé à se manifester
et que le général juin est intervenu
aussi et devant toutes ces pressions en
définitive darlan a fini par décider de
se battre avec les américains contre les
allemands sans avoir connu le télégramme
à covent il
n'est jamais retourné moral reste que je
n'admets pas pour un monsieur qui essaye
de faire un armistice comme vous le
souhaitiez les charades personne ne met
en doute votre bonne foi plus et moi
je voudrais je vous donne pour son
bouquin mais ça fait d'ailleurs une
suite d'erreurs mais je voudrais qu'il
rectifie ça vous expliquerai avec
monsieur paxon après l'émission nous
aurons tout le temps pour ça non
maîtrise a remis une couche je voudrais
lui fut répondu s'il vous plaît d'un mot
d'un bris
vous êtes inquiétés de savoir si
maréchal pétain avait une politique
c'était une revanche du front populaire
est-ce que vous avez précisé dans votre
livre d'accord que c'était la chambre du
front populaire qui lui avait donné les
pleins pouvoirs vous savez que c'est la
chambre du front populaire il veut
donner violent
alors c'était front populaire qui a
donné le et alors il ya une chose qu'il
faut préciser il ya eu 80 votes style
hostile aux pleins pouvoirs mais il n'y
a pas eu un seul vote hostile à
l'armistice
vous avez la parole est libre et autres
c'était trop tard mais il était très
étonné que j'aurais du mal
c'est très important c'est la lettre que
l'amiral y est adressé au maréchal
pétain et qui a été lu à son procès vous
ne la connaissez pas elle est très
importante
pendant cette période c'est à dire la
période durant laquelle l'animal y était
l'ambassadeur des états unis à vichy car
en ce pays
qui avait un gouvernement illégitime ils
avaient tous les ambassadeurs et bien là
me rallier a écrit ceci pendant cette
période j'ai tenu en très haute estime
votre amitié personnelle et votre
dévouement au bien du peuple français
pendant cette période vous avez à
diverses occasions et à ma demande agit
contre les désirs de lax défavorablement
à la cause alliée dans tous les cas vous
n'avez pas accepter mes recommandations
de vous opposer aux puissances de lax en
refusant leur demande la raison à
l'aider et voilà la réponse à bien des
questions qui ont été posées et des
questions posées par les téléspectateurs
la raison a légué était qu une telle
action positive
aboutirait à une haute pression
supplémentaire de votre pays par les
envahisseurs
j'avais alors et j'ai maintenant la
conviction que votre but principal était
le bien et la protection du peuple
abandonné de france
pas d'hésitation s'il voudrait c'est
intéressant quoique dans la buse
pourquoi je ne ferai pas équitation
est-ce que la muraille et n'a rien
conclure les actions de la france une
réponse qualité ordinaire que le chef
d'état major des présidents au
secteur minier s'il vous plaît si vous
n'avez ni avec les amis agira comme ans
mais que je suis arrivé là et comment
toi ce jour l'état vigile est sûr que
nous n'avons pas matériellement le temps
ce soir de passer en revue tout ce qui
s'est passé autour de vichy pendant le
gouvernement de vichy jeu comme joindre
un pointu et lg avec monsieur telle
jeanne et du moral apparente secondes à
la question vous avez posé une
alimentation tiré de la m de la lettre
d'admirables et je réponds au moyen
d'une citation de l'amiral enfants
je lui emprunte parakou trois lignes il
y a des absolus
qu'un pays humaniste n'a pas le droit de
ne pas respecter
la fin fût ce le refoulement des
allemands c'était à notre geagea nous
résistants étaient prononcées la fin fût
ce le repliement des allemands ne
justifie tenue justifié pas l' usage
criminel de n'importe quel moyen et bien
c'est sale procès il s'agit de savoir si
pour faire la politique de la
collaboration on pouvait utiliser
n'importe quel moyen refuge des moyens
criminels c'est ça la question
liée à
répondre oui mais on m'a dit la fin ne
justifie pas tous les moyens je suis
absolument d'accord mais alors je pose
la question de la résistance car on
porte misty je n'ai pas eu le temps
d'achever
l'armistice a été conclue sous le signe
de la convention de la haye autrefois la
convention de la haye interdisait les
sabotages et les attentes à druelle
permettait l'espionnage tous les
français en ont usé bras comme les
autres mais par les sabotages pas les
attentats dru et ceci vous explique les
sections spéciales et tout cas
d'armistice et de juin 48 les
communications ne résistait pas mais à
partir d'août 41 ils sont mis dans le
bain à faire leur guerre et leur faire
leur guerre avec des moyens qui n'était
pas sûr de la formation de l'est pour
une raison que la russie soviétique
n'avait pas signé la convention de la
haye de la russie tsariste l'a pas
reconnu c'était une plus tard des
catastrophes de sur fond de l'est
d'ailleurs et c'est ça qui a pourri
l'armistice et pas autre chose
l'armistice était fait pour une
situation de guerre plastique une
citation de guerre où on respecter un
minimum de morale ou en effet en
employés pas tous les moyens d esprit
pour atteindre le vichy les employés
tous et les pires nez dans mes éliminer
ce cas comment se gèrent pour ie6
l'amiral sont à la peine ce qui est
pourri l'armistice c'est le pire de
chaque konono mais c'est nyakuri
l'armistice et le viol de la convention
de la haye par les communistes et qui
peu à peu a transformé notre guerre en
guerre subversive et nous sommes dans
les conséquences alors là monsieur le
front à la parole mais l'armistice rien
là pourri il était pourri au départ il
n'est pas possible de faire un pacte
avec le diable sans se brûler les mains
vous nous parler de la convention de la
haye mais c'est un peu dérisoire quand
on connaît dachau quand on connaît doha
quand on connaît même les coptes
concentration français qui était douce
et los andes junin 6 mai mais écoutez
vous l'ignoriez pas quand même qu hitler
et les nazis en 1940 n'ai pas fait cela
on avait parlé long du parc dames 1 j'ai
repris corps est jusqu en août 41 et ce
moment là nous sommes tombés de la gare
sud mais parce que vous aviez fait un
pacte avec le diable
vous ne pouviez pas de vent étaient à
brandir la convention de la haye se
réveille et se déchaîneront par les
annales de doha et mais laissez moi
parler n'est ce pas vous ne pouvez pas
brandir la convention de la haye devant
hitler et vous aurais ri au nez il avait
d'autres principes en avance et faire la
gorge
oui mais enfin écoutez se battre sur la
convention de la haye quand la france
est entièrement occupée cote l'armistice
et violées depuis le premier jour
jusqu'au dernier est ce que ce n'est pas
peu dérisoire ça n'a aucun rapport mais
la france ne pouvait occuper le premier
jour de la non mais l'investissent a été
violée dès le départ
aux horreurs il y en a eu des deux côtés
oui mais non pas il est a u r 100000
exécutions sommaires à la libérale mais
bon là on veut non non non non non non
non mais
il ya eu celui des
messieurs j'apporte une est sûr
[Musique]
qu'elles n'étaient pas ou donnée par le
gouvernement à l'été elle ne
bronche là elles ont souvent été
ordonnée par maurice schumann mais vous
multipliez par dit vous savez vous est
d'ailleurs dans je les retrouvais dans
les faits pâture là l'officier mais m m
personnes d'accord avec vous sur le
chiffre que vous citez mais c'est
franchement ses rangs non mais c'est pas
encore en vie des anciens combattants la
donne est désolé monsieur dick six mois
et monsieur tixier me disent on était
ailleurs qu'il adviendra du groupe est
rare on a donné le chiffre de 42 caméras
dans la maîtrise journée enfin je
suppose que vous êtes de bonne foi en
vous apportant les vous permettez je
permettais je suppose que vous êtes de
bonne foi enfin bon c'est évident alors
à ce moment il faudrait peut-être
connaître des travaux qui ont été faits
depuis comme arctic sea a déclaré senna
qui ont été faits par exemple en
recherchant pour les gens un parent qui
ont été fusillés et vous vous apercevrez
avec à partir de ce moment le chiffre
que vous avez avancé il faut il est
multiplié par dix exactement par dix et
deuxièmement vous souhaitez vous citez
reverra rond mais comme vous le faites
très souvent hélas je vais en donner un
tout petit point derrière vous souhaitez
les textes qui vous convient n'est pas
ce qui ne vous conviennent pas
totalement vous avez parlé c'est moi où
j'ai décidé je vais vous avez tout à
leur parler de montoir vous avez cité le
compte rendu publié par le l'interprète
fuite vous avez cité celui qui l'a
publiée dans ses mémoires écrits dix ans
après et vous n'allez pas citer celui
qui l'a rédigé le soir-même donc alors
maintenant j'en arrive aux milliers je
vais vous allez vous venez visiter
robert aron vous n'hésitez pas la
seconde édition de robert à bon je ne
souhaitais pas cette seconde édition
pourquoi vous ne la connaissez pas et
vous ne citez pas parce qu'elle va
contre votre raisonnement parce que les
gros bras est arrivé c'était un homme
honnête et son livre sur vichy et un
livre dépasser mais un livre honnête oui
bon un livre on a dépassé mes autres se
dit dépassée en même temps quand on a
beaucoup de copains qui n'a pas beaucoup
de documents qui n'a pas connu et bien
leur glace publié cette statistique il a
commis l'erreur suivante et s'est servi
d'une enquête qui avait été fait par la
gendarmerie française et comme on avait
mal expliqué aux gendarmes ce qui devait
rechercher ils ont inscrit dans les
victimes du fait de la résistance les
victimes du fait des allemands y compris
les secours et comprenait y compris en
radio c'est à dire que je ne sont pas
des gens qui ont été tuées par un homme
existence ce sont des gens qui sont
victimes de l'ensemble des événements de
la libération y compris ceux qui ont été
tués par les allemands à oradour et
ailleurs et d'en quête du graal en vers
et des résultats vous si vous en faites
une bonne critique nous l'utiliserons
nous arrivons maintenant à des
estimations même n'est pas définitive
nous estimons qu'il ya eu entre 10 à 15
mieux exécutions sommaires sur les
petites cages ville de trou ses 15000
potro c'est fort possible mais nous
étions se fera en pleine guerre civile
alors là faut pas être temps de
l'armistice faux pas de la révolution
nationale est ce que vous ne dites pas
c'est que la première épuration c'est
vichy qu'il a fait et je reviens à mon
exemple danois on n'a pas et purée au
danemark à la fin de 1940 il y avait
3000 fonctionnaires qui avaient perdu
leur poste il y en avait dix mille qui
avait été déplacée pourquoi rôle de
protection du maréchal pétain tel qu'il
était communiste délits d'opinion parce
qu'il était franc maçon alors là on a
parlé de 1936 c'est du moulin de
labarthe est qui dit que le maréchal
pétain estimait qu'un juif après tout
n'avait pas choisi d'être juif ne pas
relâcher trop chiche ce cadre qu un
exemple j'ai été révoqué par le maréchal
je suis ni juif ni fromage et ils
étaient et ils étaient formation de
moroges et il était franc-maçon qu'il
avait choisis dont il était beaucoup
plus coupable par conséquent quand on
passe de la protection du maréchal
pétain belle c'est moi rire la
population a été mieux protégés là où il
n'y avait pas de gouvernement si on
discutait avec les allemands vers lui
dans un journal sous l'initiative
célèbre que si pétain n'avait pas été là
il y aurait eu cent mille de plus de
portée c'est ignorer complètement dans
quelles conditions des juifs ont été
arrêtées et du côté on les a recensés
si on ne l'avait pas reçue les allemands
ne les aurait jamais trouvé ils ont fait
confiance au gouvernement de vichy ils
sont venus s'inscrire on les a assignés
à résidence d'après la police française
est venus les arrêter et s'il y avait du
gouvernement le chaos leicester ou
n'importe quoi d'autre ou d'oridion à ce
moment et ce serait méfier et ils se
seraient cachés et on n'oserait pas
trouvé voilà par conséquent la façon
dont les avantages déjà un pro tu l qui
pourrait dire que ça a été un malheur il
est une zone libre allons donc bien mais
alors je réponds à ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure quand j'ai été élu
dans les andes
quand j'ai été élu député en 1951
la première question que j'ai posée à un
ministre c'est précisément celles des ex
exclure des exécutions sommaires et la
réponse a été
14800 je peux me tromper tu attendais
mais le ministre de l'intérieur
socialiste avait déclaré 104/1000 et je
vais vous donner lecture d'une
déclaration qui a été faite à
l'assemblée nationale par françois
mitterrand qui bien que ayant été voilà
tout de même quelque chose de
symptomatique un porteur de la
francisque ce qui prouve que la france
la plus diverse pouvait être derrière le
maréchal car c'est vrai que françois
mitterrand avait la francisque et si ça
vous intéresse je vous lirai ce qu'était
le serment de là francis et bien
voilà ce que disait voilà ce que disait
françois mitterrand sur les perses
intéresse tout le monde combattant 39 40
92230 trois combattants désarmés la
libération 19
1940-1945 57 1221 combattants des ffi 24
1440 incorporé de force dans la
wehrmacht 27 mille disparus des
catégories précédentes dix mille
prisonniers de guerre 38000 déportés
cent cinquante mille victimes civiles
pour cause diverses
qui ne sont pas les bombardements 97,8
victimes civiles par bombardement 55
mille victimes civiles dossier ouvrir
36000 des fusillés c'est encore un
chiffre qui est bouleversant 30000 ce
qui prouve que lorsque le parti
communiste dit qu'il est parti des 75000
fusillés ça n'est pas exact il ya eu
trente mille fusillé par les allemands
voilà donc le chiffre donné par françois
mitterrand sol j'ai donné tous les
chiffres que j'avais et les proverbes et
celui de robert monsieur eugène dié
garde des sceaux à l'époque est ce que
vous confirmez les chiffres donnés par
un salut qui journée je confirme ce qu'a
dit monsieur michel qui me paraît
parfaitement exact il est vrai qu'une
enquête menée par la gendarmerie a
confondu à la fois les fusils et les
déporter les victimes de désalement les
victimes de la répression et que le
chiffre le chiffre qui me paraissent
scientifiquement établi à l'heure
actuelle ces 14 me mais je vous dit m
très fermement que ces 14 me de trop
bien écoutez monsieur je suis désolé
mais le temps qui nous est imparti s'est
écoulé depuis largement et monsieur van
nouvelle cuisine en tant que historiens
belge de la deuxième guerre mondiale je
vous laisse le soin de conclure
il veut mais très court
ouais simplement posée aux participants
cette question si tous les français tous
avaient suivi comme un seul homme pétain
et ses recommandations
si tous y est peint celle qui est près
unam pour lutter contre les allemands où
se seraient trouvés la france en 44 se
trouverait associé avec hitler dans le
camp des vaincus elle se serait couverte
les mains de sang jusqu'aux coudes c'est
à dire qu'il aurait été déshonoré dont
ils ont qu'à la fin de son histoire s'il
vous plaît ne rouvrons pas le débat
donnée par l'amiral darlan vivant
monsieur le commandant non sur le fond
vous avez fait allusion au discours que
nous avons entendu tout à l'heure ce
discours a été un discours imposé au bas
duquel le maréchal pétain a écrit
pendant sa gardé dans son cas elle dans
son bureau pendant longtemps si je
prononce le discours je vais
dresser la france contre moi et je vais
provoquer des difficultés ou ce n'est
pas exact oui d'accord
mais il a prononcé ce discours lui avait
été imposée à une époque où il était
véritablement prisonniers avec un
geôlier qui s'appelait end fink et il a
dit je refuse de le prononcer et c'est
sous la menace et la prison ferme et ses
sous non
pas par les obliger c'est précisément
pour protéger c'est le contraire
pour tromper m on va le savait et la
parole s'est déjà fait monsieur vendredi
plus jeunes un mot conclusions eh bien
je crois que le débat s'est développée
sur deux plans distincts les uns pendant
d'intention les autres de fait est que
une étude comparée des régimes
d'occupation rappellerait peut-être une
vérité assez évidente c'est que les
meneurs du jeu étaient les allemands
qu'il y ait des prête-noms ou bien et
moi j'ajouterai simplement une chose
c'est que je pensais que 25 ans après la
mort de philippe pétain on aurait pu
parler de tout ce qui s'est passé en
france entre 1940 et 1944 avec moins de
passion je l'avais dit je crois en
présentant cette émission et que je vois
je constate je ne dis pas que je le
regrette car c'est pas fait que ces
patients ne sont pas encore apaisée
alors peut-être que dans quelques années
mais personnellement je ne serai plus là
on pourra de nouveau parler de cette
période avec disons un peu plus de
sérénité je remercie tous les
participants qui ont bien voulu
s'associer à cette émission et vous
aussi invité les spectateurs qui avaient
veillé tard ce soir on vous suivent je
l'espère jusqu'au bout rendez-vous à
mardi prochain pour un nouveau dossier
de l'écran bon train
[Musique]